Õpetaja: Ma näitan siis seda, et. Ee. Mul on siin ka Täna hommikul rongis. Tegin ruttu ühe skill I.
Õpetaja: Tegin selle Skill I, et tulla järgi. Eile tegin kahe Skill I. Ee. Kõik on kõik kohal ka. Vaata, ma tean Raine ei tule täna teeb kaugelt. Ja keegi karin. Vot jah, Karinal ikka ütles, et ta täna
Õpetaja: Jah, kodus.
Õpetaja: Madisel on puudu. Kes seal äärest on puudu? Ma ei Näe, lugeda. Niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ahah, okei, Karin. Siis ma tean. Ee, Rain, Tean, Henri on puudu. Põhimõtteliselt Ja Marina ka. Jah, okei,
Õpetaja: kuulge, aga nii. Ühesõnaga siis igal juhul andme kuuma, mis tuleb. See tuleb. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, näiteks. Mul on praegu siin mingisugune suht Lühikene chat, aga mingi chat Mul Siin on ee ikkagi olemas, et arutasime siin, et kuidas seda saada nii kui panna Ee, kaldkriips.
Õpetaja: Ee, eksport.
Õpetaja: Okei, Enter Copy to Cliport. Noh, mällu Save to File
Õpetaja: tekitab niukse Faili. Annab Faili nimeks ka. Veel Ee, mingisuguse võimaluse muuta faili nime Ma soovin teha uut Skill i eeskujul bla blabla. Mida iganes saaks selle ära muuta,
Õpetaja: ega seda siis midagi muud ei teegi, kui nüüd vaadata, siin Ee, vaadata Files.
Õpetaja: Noh, selle ma, ee. Panen ka. Ad kit, Mis ma tegin nüüd siin just rongis. Näed, ta tegi faili lihtsalt ja ta paneb kuskile lihtsalt juurkausta Põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: on siin niimoodi. Ja siis, kui sa lahti teha. Noh, tekst.
Õpetaja: Nii omavaheline vestlus.
Õpetaja: Ütlesin talle siin pikalt, et ee Soovin uut skill I teha ja siis ta jääb Ib, et idee järgi on võimalik ka teha niukene asi panna rahulikult arvuti kinni,
Õpetaja: kui vaja, Siis lihtsalt viitad sellele failile või kopid Mingit? Osa teksti, näiteks ainult. Või või Miks mitte ka kontroller ka? Vaata, kui see terminal töötab, siis, ee. Lihtsalt võtta mingi osa ja hakata sellest rääkima.
Õpetaja: Chat on veel pikk ka nagu mingi. Terve päeva. Oled seal loistanud? Ee, Tahad võibolla konteksti hoida, nii et ka see ka. See võimalus on nagu täitsa olemas.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis natukene veel. Mis ma tegin selle, ma Kustutan ära
Õpetaja: Mm, lasta. Alla. Isegi siin Lasta alla. Ee, mis ma tegin veel siis on? Ma Tegin ühe uue skill I kui teate Skille laadida. Ee, teil vaikimisi. Nad ei ole siis ee terminalist.
Õpetaja: Kirjutate Blu kin ja tegelikult leiate siit selle, et Active mingi skill id, on Ka need Ennem ei ilmu nagu Skill. Idesse
Õpetaja: kirjutada, Skill. Et siis mis tuleb? Nagu vaata, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, minul siis Skill ide all on? Siis tegin juurde niukse asja nagu
Õpetaja: Skill Transcript Ee, õppematerjal loo alge sõbralik õppematerjal eesti keeles, videotranskriptist ja salvestuse bla, bla. Bla toks kausta.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis, kui vaadata ka siin. On meie. Need videod, mis olid ennem lihtsalt kuupäevad. Aga nüüd on koos ee, teemade kaupa ja ajad. Aga veel parem on see, et kui te nüüd teete lahti toks
Õpetaja: ja vaadata vaadata materials transcriptiv ise on siin. Neid tegelikult väga Pikalt ei ole mõtet hoida. Nad on mingid päris suured asjad. Ee Zoom on väga, väga halb eestikeelses kui teha mingi lahti ja hakata. Oota,
Õpetaja: Jah, jah, no las ta siia. See koordib. Okei, siin on veel enam vähem. Okei,
Õpetaja: ee, ma teen Screenshare. I nii. Teeme siis korda Kui te hakkate lugema, siis tegelikult siin vahepeal ikka paneb ikka väga võssa. Paneb nagu ikka väga, väga läheb, aga õnneks Chat saab aru.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis on kõik videod alates ee, tänasest esimesest kuupäevast kuni viimaseni. Aga mul seal Scripti sees oli ka see, et vaata. Ka koodibaasi ja too sealt näiteid. Kahjuks need vanad vanad videod. Ta toob näited nagu hetkel koodibaasi pihta Vaata
Õpetaja: aga, vahet pole, kõik teemad on olemas, et kui me hakkame siit. Noh, ühe asjalikumad videot, hakkad sellest teisest videost. Võibolla on ju.
Õpetaja: Ee, see oli siis.
Õpetaja: No vaatame, mis Siin Video on
Õpetaja: sisukord Development Ring Ee. Miks nõuded teel muutuvad? See oli tegelikult siis swing. Pigem vist küberturvalisus cloud. Projekti kontekst htmeil. Ei Ole programmeerimis keel. Htmeili faili. Kell Need templid on ka, millel videost vaadata Otsida.
Õpetaja: Pildid ja alt. Atribuudid, Ide, shortcut, Id, infod, Kõik, mis Me oleme arutanud, kui ma tean midagi muud. Sain lahti.
Õpetaja: Võibolla võtame siit kuskilt. Ee, kus juba tulevad Mingid Ee Css Id asjad.
Õpetaja: No Siin on muutujad. Ma võtan korra selle. Võibolla kuskil siin. Võibolla Css. Näiteks
Õpetaja: Mis on Csss? Miks Instain on halb vaikimise valik ja kui nüüd vaadata neid teemasid hüperlingid,
Õpetaja: kust algab video, millest ta räägib,
Õpetaja: jääpib uuesti ja uuesti lahti, Nagu põhimõtteliselt et mingid analoogiad asjad.
Õpetaja: Teil on tegelikult kõik õppematerjalid olemas. Teil on videod olemas. Teil on need ee. Tehtud niiöelda kokkuvõtted koos õppematerjalide analoogide skeemidega kõigega põhimõtteliselt lihtsalt hakka läbi vaatama. Ja kas see sind kõnetab nagu,
Õpetaja: ee, pluss kooli. Niiöelda, mida iganes Searchida kõik materjalid on olemas,
Õpetaja: et, ee, see nüüd on tõesti, Ee, mis on teil parim asi? Te võite, Mida iganes siin lugeda, on mingi küsimusi? No palun väga, tee endale see Cloud lahti.
Õpetaja: Loed Mingisuguse lõigu Siit sellest ei saa täpselt aru, et mis mis on mõeldud hoopi paistis ja lihtsalt see tekst ja ütles, et, Kuule, räägi,
Õpetaja: Räägi lähemalt.
Õpetaja: Kõik on olemas.
Õpetaja: Ee, kuidas olete kasutanud Või sa tead, seda on ka olemas selline, et sa kutsud oma Ai sinna zoomi vestlusesse, siis ta teeb ka eesti keeles ka paremini. Ja ta teeb ka kokkuvõttes oma platvormi.
Õpetaja: Aga räägi siis lähemalt, kuidas see käib, Mis Asi on Fire.
Õpetaja: Aa, ei, on ju
Õpetaja: mul mul. Ma ütlen kohe Ära mul vale see.
Õpetaja: Aa, okei. See oli siis mingi majas. Oi, Ma vihkan sedaot. Näed? Noh, õhk kui rõve.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast ma ei tahagi ühel päeval enam seda Googleit kasutada. Ma olen saanud niimoodi ühe korra Kaheksakümmend eurot Tappa lennukipiletitega.
Õpetaja: Ee, et ee. Mingi Jah, Stignetti Punkt E.
Õpetaja: Aga proovimegi. Ee, ma ütlen kohe ära. Mul Tegelikult on üks väikene Mure ka. Ee, mul on. Täna on. Ee.
Õpetaja: Ma olen lasteaia hoolekogus. Ka Esimesel päeval pandi küll kassapidajaks ja hoolekogu liikmeks ka. Vaata, Kui ma koju läksin, siis Mu naine naeris lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Ja seal olid need rollid. Vaata, see oli protokolli. Ei, seda küll ei taha teha. Esimest Ei, sa ei soovi. See on mingi viis inimest on.
Õpetaja: Ja siis kes kes sai protokolli ja rolli nagu mingi rekordi pea. Noh, kui Kuuled kusagilt neti avarustest. Kurat,
Õpetaja: müü protokolli Mingi kolmel viimasel miitingul, nagu ei ole saanud kuidagi kohale tulla. Ja siis iga kord keegi peab tegema. Ja Nüüd siis põhimõtteliselt see esinaine, kes meil on Madli ütles nagu. Ai. No äkki saad sina alla protokolli ja no mine pekki, Nagu päriselt vä Õnneks see lasteaed ise teeb mingi põhja juba valmis. Nagu mis me arutame?
Õpetaja: No ma ei viitsi mul on midagi muud ka elus teha, siis ma mõtlesin täna. Vaata, et võtan selle tsabra kaasa. Vaata, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ja siis võtan selle jabra kaasa ja panen Zoomiga. Aga ma vaatan. See Zoom toodab niukest kuradi selle. Ma ütlesin, et see peab kindlasti olema lihtsalt mingisugune asi, mis mul videot ei Olegi vaja. Mul on vaja lihtsalt reaalajas. Nagu
Õpetaja: saada nagu tekst et pärast. Ma saan võtta selle dokumendi. Vaata, mis lasteaed mulle annab. Kenasti Panen selle Description I vastu, Panen ühte kausta ja ütlen Cloudile nagu, et, noh,
Õpetaja: noppisid siis midagi, Mis jahuti veel,
Õpetaja: saab, aga siis on see. No ma tean. Näiteks Turboscribe on Niukene mis? Ee, päris hästi. Teeb Eesti keelt. Ee, tekstiks. Ma olen seda õppematerjali kasutanud. Seal on Tobe limiit. Kolmkümmend minutit. No ma võin hakkida selle
Õpetaja: kolmekümne minutilisteks klippideks ka. Kas kui Cloud I abil ee kui vaja on ju, et saab niimoodi ka,
Õpetaja: Aga, noh, lihtsam oleks kasutada mingit nagu asja, mis on selle jaoks mõeldud. Ma mõtlen, aga ma lihtsalt pakun, et mis Iganes asi on, siis tasuta. On kindlasti jälle Nagu et A la Kolmkümmend minutit või midagi taolist,
Õpetaja: aga seda võiks siis proovida, kuidas see siis töötab. Ma ei tea, proovime sisse.
Õpetaja: No automate your meeting notes.
Õpetaja: Oi, aga miks ta ei paku seda?
Õpetaja: Miks ma pean eraldi nagu seda panema. Miks ta lihtsalt email Praegu, et veel ei ole? Veel see koht, kus mingit proovi peaks panema, vist onju?
Õpetaja: Oi, kui ärevaks teeb Niuke Asi Ma olen juba ammu ju sisse logitud. Miks ta küsib?
Õpetaja: Kuidas sa tead, mida teine asi on?
Õpetaja: Aga see siit ahah Näete, juba hakkas toimuma. Mingi järgmisena oleks mingi kõne tulnud. Vaata, teil on nüüd omniva pakk ja meie paneme mingi pill koodi. Ja
Õpetaja: kes on hom, kes on saanud juba selle kõne. Vaata, et nad nagu nad teevad Nüüd niimoodi. Vaata, et mida iganes. Mul on tähitud kiri ju pakiautomaati.
Õpetaja: Mulle helistati Swed pangast.
Õpetaja: Vot helistas väga hästi Eesti Keeles rääkis
Õpetaja: kõik asjad. Pane oma asja valmis. Noh, koolid asjad, Mingisugune ülekanne Taotlus
Õpetaja: kaheksasada number üks. Siis ühendatakse neid selle spetsialistiga ja siis meesterahvas võiks vastu.
Õpetaja: Ma küsin, et miks helistad. Miks helistad, Eks ta sai aru polegi seda korterit Ja siis. Ee.
Õpetaja: Miks sa helistad nagu selle peale
Õpetaja: ja magage aineks, et see pole ühel mees keelt,
Õpetaja: Okei, numbrit ei saanud, See on see number.
Õpetaja: Puun hakkab edasi teisel tuntavalt.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on vastikuks on läinud see elu Ja nüüd Ega see aid Asjadega läheb see asi Unable to sign in all this.
Õpetaja: No
Õpetaja: eriti nagu tegija koht ei tundu olevat. Kui me, nagu mul praegu juba Mõtlen nagu. Kas ma juba pean oma roole vahetama minema või ei pea. Vaata aga ma. Kas ma ei pannudki? See oli login vä.
Õpetaja: Oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, kus see on? Siin?
Õpetaja: Ja siis seal. Kus on Next siis enne seda.
Õpetaja: Aa, aga Kreete Google Account.
Õpetaja: Mhm, No
Õpetaja: ma ei ole mitte ühte kohta pidanud sisse logima, kui ma olen juba tegelikult Googles sees, kas ma ikka olen Õiges kohas. Fireflies.
Õpetaja: Ma vajan assistantit siia sisse logida. Ma teen eraldi lehe selle jaoks nagu Fireflies. Ee
Õpetaja: Aa, väga hea. Vaatame korra seda, Mis siis saab? Äkki saab tasuta ka midagi, Transcribe.
Õpetaja: Aga see on ikkagi. See on ikkagi Sign In. Vaata, nagu ma proovisin juba niimoodi. Ma võin seda sama. Võin seda sama liigutust veel uuesti teha. Aga siin on nagu see.
Õpetaja: Oota, aga ma ütlen, kus siin üldse on, Nagu pealehel Nagu Create New Account. Nagu. Vot see. Vot see on nagu see, nagu login on. On
Õpetaja: request. Demo on ei taha.
Õpetaja: No See viib täppi. Pead samma kohta.
Õpetaja: Ma proovida seda ka. Mingi töökontoga on turvalisem minna on ju?
Õpetaja: Kui läheb, siis läheb lihtsalt tööasjad,
Õpetaja: aga Ma läksin täpselt sealt. Ma panin loo kinni ja siis ta lasi mulle.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, kulutame siin juba aega. Ee, jah, väga hea, No tundub põnev asi olevat. Vaata, kui mingi Ai asi mis peaks su elu lihtsamaks tegema. Su elu põrguks juba kui esimesel sekundis nagu Usaldus on kadunud, aga
Õpetaja: see vahepeal küsib, kas sul on veel mingisugust emaili ja paroole?
Õpetaja: Anna meelde, aga laagi koolitusel Me pidime kõik kasutama kutsuma.
Õpetaja: No mis see kvaliteet oli? Aga see mäleta kunagi järgi vaadata, aga, noh, selles mõttes.
Õpetaja: Oh, jah, see tegelt oleks hea. Asi Okei, Pärast Võibolla vahetunni suurib. Kuulge, aga paneme nüüd edasi.
Õpetaja: Mm, ta tegi.
Õpetaja: Ee, oi, aga ma nüüd olengi üldse. Ee, kas ma tegin? Praegu Kas ma praegu teie juures tegin? Mingi või teinud või teinud on ju?
Õpetaja: Ma proovin minna korra tagasi oma Brunchile ja palvetan, et ta lubab mul võtta kaasa need Skill, Id ja asjad ning konflikti otsas ei tohiks tekkida. Minu meelest
Õpetaja: väga hea.
Õpetaja: Ma teen siis siia seda taha Siustatame ära, et
Õpetaja: nii. Ee, aga ja. Okei, siis ma tahaks nüüd ka ühte asja proovida. Või võime korra proovida. Ma tegelikult tahaks tuunida seda veel veidi Ee järgi tulemine.
Õpetaja: Nii ma kõigepealt teen, siis Ee bushi. Lihtsalt selles samas arvus, kus ma ennem toimetasin,
Õpetaja: kui mitte Ainult buss.
Õpetaja: Nii, selle korra ajutise asja ma korra kustutan ära.
Õpetaja: Nüüd mina tulen. Ee, Mängin ka kohe kui see push on, Ee, ära Tehtud pluss pluss. Pluss
Õpetaja: nagu lapse sünd. Vaata, oi, ma ei tea oma naisega. Kui käisime sünnitamas. See ikka oli. Jah,
Õpetaja: Ta pidi Push Ima.
Õpetaja: See oli ikka pikk üritus.
Õpetaja: Noh, näed, tita tuli. Jess,
Õpetaja: Nii, teie võite nüüd fetšida. Mis mina taustal teen, On See ma. Teen Väikse fake konto
Õpetaja: või fake Haru. Ma teen, ee, ühe uue New Branch. Ja ma panen mitte õpetaja, vaid ma panen rainu.
Õpetaja: Ahah See On see hellitav nimi, mida väga harva kuuleb.
Õpetaja: Ja ma mängin, et. Ee. Ma olen mahajäänud.
Õpetaja: Kui te teete, tulete järgi ja tahate seda Uut Skill I ka proovida. Võibolla esialgu proovin Mina Äkki mingi jama, onju?
Õpetaja: Kuidas Ta tehtud on? Me võime korra vaadata ka, Ega see On ju teksti kujul kõik kenasti olemas.
Õpetaja: Ee, catch up feature branche. Aga ma ütlen, ma tegelikult tuuniks ta hästi natukene veel ringi, aga Savi üles alla. Tuvasta hetkearu ja salvesta nimi. Tühista lahtised muudatused. Kustuta versioonimata failid. Õp. Otsi õpetaja Remote,
Õpetaja: mis algavad õpetaja origin otsijate harude seas. See, mis? Mille number klapib? Õpilase haruga
Õpetaja: Noh, teie olete ka näiteks. Ee, rainu Feb. Seitse Kas Õpetaja. Feb Seitse on olemas, kui ei leiad täpselt sobiva aru. Jätka automaatselt, Kui leiad mitu sobivat aru? Küsi kasutajat, Millist arvuti sobib kasutada ja oota vastust kui ühtegi sobivat Arvutit ei aavita kasutajat, küsi mida teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, uus haru õpetaja. Haruld määru haaru nimi. Võta õpilase vana haru nimi, lisa versiooni number ala stiilis See see uus. Nimi. Kui Vana haaru nimel on versiooni number, siis lihtsalt suurenda numbrit.
Õpetaja: Käivitage checkout. Uusaru nimi. Võtad sealt selle kinnita Kasutajale. Tuusar on loodud. Checkout on tehtud. Ma tegelt teeksin sellest niukse variandi, et et kaks varianti. Üks on nagu, ee, mis mul selle nimi nimi oli üldse.
Õpetaja: Ee, üks on. Aa Kit Catch Up Feature Branch. Ma teeksin ühe veel niukse. Branch with back up
Õpetaja: backup ideks Niimoodi, et ta teeb üldse ja teebki uue niiöelda nimelise. Niiöelda, et ta nagu vana vana haru nimetab. Aa paneb lõppu back up
Õpetaja: ja Jääb alles ja siis sinna, Sealt seal. Siis saab vaadata, mis on muudatusi. Uus haru tuleks ilma versiooni numbrita. See on mu mõte. Vaata, Et, ee, et mõlemal juhul uus haru nimi tuleks ilma. Ee, selle Ee versiooni numbrita, et oleks Niukene ilus ja puhas. Aga Lihtsalt kui On see olukord, et mõtled? Ma pärast Tahan vaadata.
Õpetaja: Siis valid selle. Tundub, Ju Niukene. Oleks hea variant. Vaatame, kuidas see töötab. Ee, nagu Ma juba ütlesin, et see, kui te nüüd tulite samale lehele, et ma praegu veel ei soovita. Muidugi seda niikuinii proovida. Prooviks ise kõigepealt. Ah,
Õpetaja: ee,
Õpetaja: ma lihtsalt tahan näha, kas see töötab. Mul pole pole õrna aimu. Ma mängin, et ma olen Rainu vep, seitse. Ma olen õpetajast maas.
Õpetaja: Ma tahan näha, kes see töötab.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, mis juhtuma hakkab. Siis Kaua see aega võtab?
Õpetaja: Ma panin tähele, et mõned ee, mõned Comandyd. Ta tahab Siin Powershell i ka käivitada. Ja siis ta mingi mul siin. Et kui see Cloud on niiöelda läbi Windowsi terminali, siis Minu meelest tal nagu mõne asjaga. Siin, on ta teinud natuke teistmoodi, kui ma olen vees sellis.
Õpetaja: Noh, ta räägib veel, räägib sellesse
Õpetaja: no Ikka, no midagi ikka. No teksti siia. Tuli Praegult ju. Ee, aru. Pidi saama selle Mdf Faili pidi sisse lugema.
Õpetaja: Ee, ikka läheb. Jah,
Õpetaja: No vaata, me näeme ka hetke aru. On rainu veeb seitse.
Õpetaja: Ee, selle. Ma võiks öelda, et ta küsib ka on okei asi, mida teha edaspidi.
Õpetaja: Ee, ta settings. Teil on niuke personaalne fail punkt settings, kus ta nagu salvestab ära. Aa, selle See ei tohiks osa tegelikult projektist olla. Ma ei tea, kas kogemata on, et edaspidi ta ei küsiks.
Õpetaja: Ma panen jah,
Õpetaja: Kui nüüd minna vaatama sinna muudatustes, siis peaks juba siin praegult olema. Üks muudatus. Näete, see on. Ta näitab seda, et on muudatused. Luba
Õpetaja: Tegelikult see ee, Settingsfile peaks olema, ee, mitte osa projektist,
Õpetaja: et mina, muidu sa annad üle projekti õiguse. Jah, võib kõike nagu programme asju jooksutada. Keegi teine käivitab selle enda arvutis, selle Projekti kasutab ka Cloud I. Cloud Läheb, vaatab. Jah, mul on luba antud selleks tolleks ja kolmandaks, ja siis ta ei küsi üle, vaata neid asju, et see tegelikult peaks olema eraldi, et on kogemata siia sisse läinud.
Õpetaja: Ee, pole harjunud. Sa peaks Kittig noori panema kohe alguses
Õpetaja: Aga ma peaks ütlema seda, et. Ee.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, kui kaua ta seda teeb? No nüüd on valmis.
Õpetaja: Ma oleks. Mul oleks tehtud saanud juba
Õpetaja: Aga see Jebimine muidugi jääb. Ära Vaata, et kõik vajutavad nuppu. Ja kuidagi saab sa pead hakkama nagu ma. Ma täpselt ei tea, aga Umbes on see protsess. Võib olla niimoodi, et sa kitist ka enne nagu kustutad ära, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ja siis sa tekitad uuesti ja paned Kittagi saab kindlasti kuidagi. Aga see on. Parem On nagu esimesel korral saada. No Tegelikult, väga kaua ei teinud. No mis ta ütleb? Kukk, minut. Kolmkümmend kolm. Vaata, et võibolla isegi. Tegelikult see nagu mugavus ka maksab. Midagi, onju?
Õpetaja: Et näete. Raino veeb. Seitse on ju, tal on Kõik, mis on. Ee, siis õpetaja. Selle seitsme oma. Aga ma ütlen, ma tuuniks seda. Vaata, et ta tegelikult ikkagi kustutaks selle vana asja Ära
Õpetaja: seda V kahte ei tuleks, et siis, oleks nagu vähem vähem.
Õpetaja: Aga töötas ju idee
Õpetaja: et kui nüüd keegi tahab järgi tulla ja see on. Siis öelge mulle, et te tulete sellega järgi ja vaatame, kuidas teil õnnestub.
Õpetaja: Nii mina tulin nüüd tagasi selle ee, veb seitsmele, No ma annan siis selle kah juba. Ära siia
Õpetaja: selle setting siia On siis teil ka need samad käsud seal tegelt tuleks üle vaadata? Ma ütlen, et selle asja tegelikult ei saa. Väga nagu, ee.
Õpetaja: Tegelikult sellesse nendesse käskudesse ei saa väga tšillilt nagu, ee, ee suhtuda näete siin,
Õpetaja: aga siis on kirjas lokal See peaks olema lokal.
Õpetaja: Nagu mingid asjad on, mis on väga, väga fine, aga siin mina olen liiga Laisalt mingeid väga konkreetseid asju pannud. Lihtsalt jes sool. Ära küsi enam. Vaata, onju? Ära küsi,
Õpetaja: aga siin on mingid väga konkreetsed asjad nagu Leping kolm. No mul ei lähe seda vaja. Ilmselt onju, et see on mingi väga spetsiifiline. Ee, lihtsalt jälle kõik see Shellidest,
Õpetaja: et siit tegelikult peaks nagu kõik. Nagu mõtlema nagu läbi. Vaata, et saada asju Mistahes asju sobib. Ee, see on veits kahtlane seda, et saada põhimõtteliselt Võta ühendust internetiga. Mine kuskile lehele,
Õpetaja: Ee, ja nii edasi edasi. See tegelt peaks natukene üle vaatama, et see on okei, et siin on Asju, mida ta ei küsi uuesti ja uuesti. Iga Kord, kui sa paned Yes, vaata, siis on lihtsalt selle korra kohta, kui sa paned Yes for life. Vaata või for all. Siis ta siia tekitabki. Uue rea. Vaata,
Õpetaja: tema küsis, kas ma võin teha. Ma ütlesin, et jah, Edaspidi. Ära küsi, mis ta tegi. Ta pani oma settingute alla, Et Allow. Näete Allow
Õpetaja: edaspidi. Ta saab Fetchida ilma probleemita.
Õpetaja: Sa ise ei hakka tegema, kui sa talle ei ütle. Tee midagi
Õpetaja: ja. Aga vaata, kui mina suhtlen ja ütlen talle, me suhtlen omavahel ja tema toimetab ta ju tuimalt kogu aeg paneb. Igast asja. On ju iga kord, Kui ta tegelikult ju midagi küsib. Vaata, siis ta küsib, et kas Ma võin jooksutada mingit käsku,
Õpetaja: Kitt või mis iganes. Tegelikult. Iga kord. Sa peaksid niimoodi ilusti nagu lugema ja üritama aru saada aga kui Sul on, see, et ta teeb siin mingi virrvarju et mingi failide sees mingi vahetab asju ja toimetab ja teeb, Noh, mina hakkad seda ka lugema. Või Noh, loodame. Palvetame. Vaata, onju,
Õpetaja: et, ee, et siin on nagu väikene väike Niuke Truston ka nagu ee siin olemas, aga No ütlen, et kas kui niimoodi. Noh, ma saaksin ka muidugi analüüsida seda. Vaata, et ma võiksin öelda, et. Kuule, mis on siin. Nagu Ohtlikud käsud,
Õpetaja: mis on nagu ohtlikud, mis? Nagu muuta me saaks ka seda ära muuta. Edaspidi ta ei küsi onju, aga ma seda see Ma ütlen, et see natukene muutub. Nüüd. Ee, praegu. Neil on uus feature mode. Mingi auto.
Õpetaja: Ee, Mis saab olema niimoodi, et, ee, nad on ehitanud uue filatuuri juurde. Vaata, mis ee. Kit otsustab sinu eest ise, Cloud ise. Sinu eest otsustab, et mis käske ta peab, Nagu turvaliseks. Ja mis, mida? Et Sa annad talle rohkem autonoomiat, Et sa ei pea kogu aeg panema jah, jah,
Õpetaja: tee vaid. Sa annad talle Nagu niukse voli, üle et sa ise. Sa ise otsustab. Ja siis tal on sinna mingisugused seif kaardid sisse pandud juba et ta üritab nagu Siis nagu neid. Seda mõttetut tiluliluda kogu aeg. Lihtsalt sinu eest.
Õpetaja: Ja siis kus tuleb midagi nagu, ee, Midagi niukest loeb Ee ette, Mida, mida? Tema nagu aina peab. Nagu Vaata, et okei, niuksed käsud võivad olla natuke ohtlikud, Siis tuleb oma pidurit.
Õpetaja: Vaata, eesmärk oleks see, et tegelikult ma tahaks neid neid asju näha. Et kas ma võin jooksutada seda toda Ainult siis kui seda tegelikult on vaja vaadata Ka See oleks ideaalis. Vaata aga praegult. Ee, seda autovarjanti hetkel ei ole. Vaata, see on ainult mingi. Ma ei tea, mingi Enterpriseidel ja mingi Asjadel on ta nagu peta nagu veits.
Õpetaja: Nii, aga ta ise idee järgi. Ta tegelikult töötas ja kõik on väga tiptop. Olete kõik kaasas praegu. Jah.
Õpetaja: Ee, nii, väga hea.
Õpetaja: Kuhu me jäime? Keegi mäletab Peep Seitsmega. Me midagi tegime. Igal juhul
Õpetaja: seitsmega me midagi tegime. Aa, me Tegime seda sõnumi saatmist. Võibolla teeme niimoodi, et Vaatame nüüd korra selle asja, ära. Mis me tegime.
Õpetaja: Võibolla teeme ka veel ära ja ja Siis me teeme selle asja uuesti. Aga me võtame kohe teistsuguse lähenemise. Et me võtame niimoodi, et me üritame teha niimoodi, et ta on Kohe Alguses natukene loetav ja arusaadav ja struktureeritud.
Õpetaja: Noh, ee, lähme siis kõigepealt sinna. Aa, Viewse Login View alla.
Õpetaja: Sisse. Paneme.
Õpetaja: Ee, jah, jah, See Siin on kõik see. See osa, onju? Ee, vaatame, mis meil siiamaani on. Meil on siis ee, login meetod, mis käivitub nupust. Näed, Kui ma vajutan siia Klikin Control I ka peale korra, nagu mõtleb siin praegult veel.
Õpetaja: Ta üldiselt tahaks.
Õpetaja: Ei, mitte midagi, nii Ee, et Siin üleval on Button Real. See on see nupp, mis klikib login,
Õpetaja: Login käivitub. Ee siis kõigepealt resetime error Message, käivitame Vaadake, kuidas meetodeid saab välja kutsuda. Mis on siin meetodi blokis? Ka sellele väljakutsele Peab panema disse ette,
Õpetaja: et see tähenda Kui ma. Kustutan praegu selle siit Ära Niimoodi
Õpetaja: siis tema mõtleks, et see meetod on mul kuskil Siin blokis siin üleval. Vaata, kui me ekstraktime mingit koodilõiku ja teeme tee Sest eraldi meetod. Ta Küsib, et kas sa tahad panna seda siia või sa tahad panna seda siia Methods blokki eelneva meetodi ette, vaata onju? Ja viimane variant. Ma ei mäleta, mis ta vahel pakub Seal,
Õpetaja: et ee see this viitab, et siin meetodite blokis on Niukene meetod Nagu reset message, Mis siin all ongi,
Õpetaja: on see arusaadav.
Õpetaja: Nii et esimesed tegevused on reset Ime Message I. Siis vaatame, kui kõik on korrektsed. Siis käivitame aktsiasega ket meetodi Ee, siuksele rajale. Niukeste parameetritega. Mäletate? See piibel hetkel on sisse kirjutatud. Väärtused by The way On ju
Õpetaja: Aa, see vist oleks aeg ka nagu edasi liikuda, on ju? Me ei taha, et on sisse kirjutatud. Ee, see. Ma korra panen selle Piibli ette. Kui mul veel see kuskil siin ee on.
Õpetaja: Kuskil ka siin. Näed, siin on
Õpetaja: ee. Saate minu vaates seda vaadata, Paneme piibli ette ja vaatame, et Ee, tõesti. See loginn on täpselt selline nagu me soovime. Kui ma tõmban täpselt samale reale siin niimoodi enamvähem ee on tõmb. Panen Urli juurde,
Õpetaja: Paps.
Õpetaja: Teeme siis ee. Teeme. Vahepeal paint. I ka
Õpetaja: pendiga saab ju joonistada, eksole? Ee, see on See kõige Parem maailma parim Photoshop editor. Ongi et
Õpetaja: ongi, et võtame siit järjest. Värve on login,
Õpetaja: ah? Ei, meil läks ka nüüd
Õpetaja: roheliseks. Ongi et Click. Oi, oi, oi, click, Ee, võtan siit. Ee, võtan. Vot sinise On login,
Õpetaja: on? Noh, see abi. Praegu, et me mäletame, see on see mure. Vaata, onju, et ta ei tea, kas see on Frontendile sõnum või backendile tegelikult. Mõeldud. Siis tuleb natukene. Tõmbasin julmalt, aga siin on See params.
Õpetaja: Siin on parameeters.
Õpetaja: Siis Ee, Mis värvi järgmiseks?
Õpetaja: Noh, siukene. Veider roheline on Username.
Õpetaja: Mhmh.
Õpetaja: On. Username on usernim.
Õpetaja: Nüüd lähevad Väärik kordusesse juba on. Ee, väärtus on väärtus, on ju nii?
Õpetaja: Nii on, Ee, password. Parem Siit ajal on Password
Õpetaja: ja võtame siis veel Mingi sinise näiteks ja on väärtus ja on väärtus. On piibel Siiamaani
Õpetaja: mõtle see eilne video, mis me pidime kodus vaatasiteemaline onju?
Õpetaja: Kas ee, See on see et see on see pusletsükkel, mis peaks nagu kokku minema, et me pärime täpselt samamoodi, nagu on see.
Õpetaja: Me pärime täpselt Selliselt nagu Back and server. Seda ootab
Õpetaja: Back and Server ei saa. Vaata nagu, ee. Kui me saadame sõnumi näiteks ilma username, ita
Õpetaja: siis ta. Ta ei oska seda käivitada. Ta eest.
Õpetaja: See on täpselt see, kuidas ootab seda sõnumit sisse.
Õpetaja: No nii, no ja kui minna nüüd Siit natukene edasi. Vaata, et siis on see, et kui kõik on hästi.
Õpetaja: Tegelikult ma panen siia kõrvale. Veel. Ei tee siis pilti,
Õpetaja: et Kui kõik on hästi, siis mis meie tahame teha, on see, et me tahame tegelikult
Õpetaja: teeme. Teeme niimoodi, et edaspidi ma hoian ka, vaata Need mitmekihilised, niiöelda databloki muutujad hoiab niimoodi eraldi ridadel. See on parem natukene näha.
Õpetaja: Noh, nad ei peaks olema, tegelikult, aga neil silma on veits. Parem näha, et näete. Meil on meil lõpuks kuskile vaja vastust panna.
Õpetaja: Ja kui me võtame, vaatame seda asja niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Nagu, ee, süsteemselt Jälle
Õpetaja: Nii, vaadake, Hakkame pihta nendest loogilistest sulgudest.
Õpetaja: Palun väga.
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja ainult mõelda mingi nimi juurde muutujat, sest siin ei ole. Muutujat Ei ole vaja muuta,
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd kõik Ülejäänud osa, mis on nüüd siin Vahel
Õpetaja: on sama, kui välja jätta need jutumärgid,
Õpetaja: et see Jasonis on Objektis ei ole Syntaxis. Muidu on kõik sama
Õpetaja: nii. Ja meil on vaja kuskile see vastus kinni püüda.
Õpetaja: Kuidas me seda saime teha, on see, et me saame kogu responsi koos sulgeda ja karvadega.
Õpetaja: Kõik saame niiöelda sii. See on sildikene.
Õpetaja: Siit edasi. Vaata, mis on selle Nende loogiliste sulgude vahel. On see, et peale seda noolfunktsiooni on. See, et seda kutsutakse lambaks. Lambda funktsiooniks kutsutakse selles mõttes lambamidu. Märk on Nagu teistsugune. Aga see on Lambda funktsioon.
Õpetaja: See on niimoodi, et loome ühe sildi. Ja nüüd, peale seda noolekast me ütleme, et läheb Action Iks
Õpetaja: siin Action I sees. Me saame kasutada seda sama sildikest Ja responsel sees on datablokk ja datablokk ongi lihtsalt andmed, mis tulevad siis Vastusele
Õpetaja: Ehk see liigutus siin põhimõtteliselt paneb.
Õpetaja: See on ümbrik.
Õpetaja: See asi See on ümbrik ja siis me ütleme, et Kuule, siia ümbrikule on Uus sisu,
Õpetaja: kus kohast võtta. Sealt vastusest. Aga täpsemalt Datablokk
Õpetaja: ei ole enam vist enam seda nauti alles. Vaata, kus me korra lihtsalt panime Jasonina kogu selle vastuse, et siin on mi? Siin on mitmeid asju. Vaata, siin on igasuguseid asju. Siin on mingi staatus staatus tekst aga Üks asi on. Tata
Õpetaja: on seal objekti sees. Data. Meid huvitab see data just.
Õpetaja: Mis me siis tegime? Panime Local Storage Isse Mis see Local Storage. Oli see Local Starys?
Õpetaja: Ei, Brauseris Eraldi Niukene hoidla
Õpetaja: Brauseri sisse näidata et see see ei ole meie arvutis Selles mõttes see on konkreetselt Brauseris,
Õpetaja: et kui Ee. Chroom selle Brauser selle sõnumi saadab
Õpetaja: Kui Chrome seal teeb. Chrome ju laeb ju meie veebilehe, siis saada Back end Il Saate sõnumid läbi läbi fontend serveri Niiöelda hakkab saatma muudkui sõnumid. Anna infot Anna infot Anna infot. Vaata Tegelikult seda teeb Chrome.
Õpetaja: Et kui tema saab selle vastuse kätte, vaata, siis meil on programmeeritud. Palun väga, pane nüüd siia meie Chrome või Firefoxi kuhu iganes I alla
Õpetaja: ja. Siin see süsteem oli võti väärtus.
Õpetaja: Et, ee. Kui teha korra lahti
Õpetaja: panga reserveri käima ka siis ee, saab kuhugi minna, On ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, meil on siin niukene asi nagu võti väärtus.
Õpetaja: Mul on siin see enda õppeprojekt, mis kohe läheb hästi. Ära
Õpetaja: Local Storage, Noh, nüüd peaks juba tulema.
Õpetaja: Lasen selle siit korra tühjaks.
Õpetaja: Siia saab panna siis võtmeid.
Õpetaja: Mingi nimi, Mingi väärtus.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ei tohi ära unustada, et see siin on tekst Ja see siin on tekst.
Õpetaja: Kui siin oleks näiteks True, siis ta ei ole vaid ta on lihtsalt tekst, True.
Õpetaja: Ja seal on number üks.
Õpetaja: Siis ta tegelikult on tekst. Vaata, et siia saab panna lihtsalt teksti,
Õpetaja: et sa võid panna, aga sa Pead lihtsalt arvestama, et kui sa siit andmeid võtad, et sa esialgu saad, nad tahad seda päriselt asja numbrina, siis sa pead ta seal Javascriptis numbriks tegema. Kui sa tahad seda asja, siis sa võtad selle tekstina. Aga sa teed selle niiöelda, siis,
Õpetaja: tead ja tead head ja Nii
Õpetaja: okei, aga nüüd on siis see, et praegu kui sõnum läheb sisse logimine, Kui mina panen siia Ttt ja Dtt kui inspektist vaadata, Siis hetkel see sõnum läheb.
Õpetaja: Aga läheb A ja B. W. W. Miks ta seda teeb? On see, et meil on praegu sisse programmeeritud Lihtsalt see on nagu see make It Work.
Õpetaja: Aga me ei taha, et läheb Aa või B. W. Kust meie tahame võtta, et mis läheb. Me tahame, et läheks ikkagi. Need, mis siin kastides on, on ju?
Õpetaja: Mis ma siis siia kirjutan?
Õpetaja: See asi ei sobi
Õpetaja: Ei, kirjuta. Aeg Otsed jutumärgid.
Õpetaja: Miks ju missioon on selline, Et Ee, sinna username I läheks.
Õpetaja: Ma panen korra selle tagasi. Ma ei saa teha nüüd Sinna username I läheks. See, mis on siin kastis,
Õpetaja: kui ma panen. Ma tahan, et see läheb
Õpetaja: sinna username Iks ja ma tahan, et parooli. Ma ei saa näidata ka. G. D on siin, näiteks.
Õpetaja: No aga kus?
Õpetaja: Noh, input. Noh, mis input ei saa kirjutada, Ju ma ei saa kirjutada lihtsalt koodis. Ma ei saa viidata mingile input Ile. Me ei saa viidata Html elementidele
Õpetaja: Midagi kettida ka ei ole, vaja
Õpetaja: Mis juhtus, mi? Lihtsalt kaltri ja see.
Õpetaja: No mõelge nüüd loogiliselt, kuidas. Kuidas veel kogu see asi töötab, kui mina tahan suhelda? Nagu põhimõtteliselt. Aa, kui mina tahan suhelda selle.
Õpetaja: Meil on kaks osa. Meil on Action ja meil on visuaalne pool. Ja kui ma soovin suhelda
Õpetaja: nende väärtustega, Siis mul on ainult üks ja ainus viis, kuidas ma seda teha saan. Kuidas me saame suhelda kahe maailmaga Action plus va vaade Visuaal, Ah, Tata. Okei, nii. Kas vastab tõele, et see input on seotud kahepidiselt muutuja sellise reaktiivse muutujaga username?
Õpetaja: Noh, see on see, asi Millega ma tahan suhelda. Siin ongi see info. Siin ongi. See
Õpetaja: Kui ei usu. Vaatame, teeme lahti. Ma panen siia mingi asja juba ette. Ära. Aa,
Õpetaja: Noh paneme. Ma ei, mina küsin. Mis on minu Paro parool. Vaata, ma teile ei Ütle veel, onju Noh,
Õpetaja: ma tulen. Voe, Ma võtan siin komponendid. Mul on Login View.
Õpetaja: Ma näen tata bloki, Mis on mu pääsevärd.
Õpetaja: Kas oskad tõele, et praegu, see informatsioon on Nende muutujate sees, on nii?
Õpetaja: Nii, Nüüd tuleme selle küsimuse juurde. Tagasi. Siin Mina ei taha, et läheks sinna Username väärtus. Aa, mis ma Tahan siia kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Siis siis
Õpetaja: punkt username. Ma viitan siin sellele,
Õpetaja: nagu ma klikin siia ka. Vaata, kuhu ta kukub. Ülesse siia, alla, kuhu Ta kukub
Õpetaja: ülesse. Kas see tundub loogiline?
Õpetaja: See, kuna, Noh, me teame, et selline on see setup
Õpetaja: Meie ainus viis omavahel niiöelda neid kahte maailma ühendada. Ma, noh, ma olen seda pilti juba näidanud, aga vaatame siis ühe korra veel, onju, et, ee, see see on see asi, Mis Te peate hakkama? Nagu aru saama. Kui te selle aru saate, siis juba läheb elu lihtsamaks.
Õpetaja: Te peate sellest aru saama, meil on visuaal.
Õpetaja: Ja meil on mingi action. Mis on Yaha?
Õpetaja: Ainuke asi, Vahet pole, mis suunas.
Õpetaja: Tahad sinna midagi näidata Läbi data bloki. Tahad sealt midagi kätte saada Läbi data bloki.
Õpetaja: Tahad seda või? Või tuvid?
Õpetaja: Nii, okei, saime selle paika. No teeme selle teise ka ära.
Õpetaja: Issand, kui hullult. Ma panen asja kinni ja kuidagi väga, väga s Slogan koos. Asi, see on
Õpetaja: nii. Kus sa oled? Siis Siia kirjutan siis
Õpetaja: this Punkt Password.
Õpetaja: No nüüd saab juba rallida. Jälle ma ütlen, aga ma saan panna. Siia.
Õpetaja: Panen siia, panen Network.
Õpetaja: Saadan login.
Õpetaja: Ee, tõesti, Refresh I taustal Praegult
Õpetaja: on nii? Igaks juhuks panen mingid teistsugused väärtused siia mingi aad otsa. Mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Noh, tundub, et töötab. Sõnumid lähevad nende väärtustega Näed, Pailo D, on ju nii
Õpetaja: nii? Nüüd on see asi nagu selles mõttes dünaamiline. Vaata, et meil ei ole sisse kirjutatud siin Mingisugused väärtused.
Õpetaja: No see sõnusa saatmine. Selles mõttes on kõik väga hästi. Vastuse saame ka kätte. Kenasti. Ee, tip, top.
Õpetaja: Väga Hea Local Storesisse. Paneme asjad maha.
Õpetaja: Vaata, mis edasi peab saama.
Õpetaja: Aa, okei, Ta räägib. Ee, liiku. Ta Räägib Errori ka ära, aga siis ta räägib ka Liikumine vaatajale. Atms, Atm, S
Õpetaja: ja saavutus peab saama. Okei, see tegelt on ikka eraldi. Osa. Seal on see kättesaamise osa ka.
Õpetaja: Teeme selle hiljem. See. Ma saan panna endale väikse Too niimoodi tuudu navigeeri.
Õpetaja: Vaatame siis nii väikene reminder iseendale.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, kui te panete mistahes kommentaari ja Panete selle sõna to Do, siis ta esiteks on kollane. Teiseks, meil on olemas Niukene tööriist
Õpetaja: nagu To Do.
Õpetaja: Kui sul on üle projekti To do. Siis ta leiab need kõik Ülesse
Õpetaja: saad vaadata. See on endale nagu et meelespea.
Õpetaja: Ära Ära unusta, et midagi on veel vaja teha.
Õpetaja: Kuidas on
Õpetaja: Ee. Niukene Eraldi Ta vaikimis ei ole peal alati. See on see tööriist Do. Panin selle lihtsalt praegult peale
Õpetaja: siit alt
Õpetaja: väga Ei, kasuta seda. Ütlen ausalt. Ma Tavaliselt, kui ma kirjutan to do. Mul on mingi to do. Vaata, mingi hetk ma pikin ülesse ka idee järgi. Ta on nagu parem, kui päriselt on tegemist. To Douga. Vaata, On parem panna seda ette, Vähemalt siis sa saad selle üles leida. Ja tegelikult hakkab midagi ninguma ütlema, et. Aa, sul on seal. To do. Ära unusta asja nagu okei? Okei,
Õpetaja: ta siis nagu Aitab ka veidi. Nagu meeles hoida, et sa ära päris ikka ei unustaks. Nagu ikka tuleb ära teha, et nagu, et ma ei, noh. Ei saa nagu jätta
Õpetaja: Mm, kommentaaridest. Nii palju võib rääkida. Ma olen kommentaare, et ei peaks olema välja arvatud siis, kui on mingisugune väline Informatsioon
Õpetaja: mida seal koodilõigus on kriitiline teada ja seda lihtsalt ei ole võimalik koodist välja lugeda. Siis on nagu võib alati öelda, et see on õigustatud. Juhul kui see on kriitiline. Lhv S. Ma Nägin ainult ühte projekti, kus oli, ee, üks ainus kommentaar et oli kommentaar
Õpetaja: ja See kommentaar oli selline. See oli. Vähemalt see kommentaar oli mingi neli, viis aastat. Vana. Ee, noh, kommentaarid sai vaadata, kes selle ka kirjutas
Õpetaja: Ja siis kommentaar oli ajaljärgnev, Et, Ee, see siin on häkk selle peaks ümber tegema.
Õpetaja: Iga kord, kui ma tegin mingeid muudatusi, siis ma Palvetasin, et Jumala eest ühtegi muudatust sinna faili ei Tule Ütleb, et. Kuule, aga siin on kommentaar. Sa ju omaette nägid seda? Noh, see Mingi eraldi taask. Nagu mingi aga tehniline värk. Ta töötas ilmselt,
Õpetaja: aga ei olnud kindlasti optimaalne.
Õpetaja: Ma, arvan, et kõik panid samamoodi ka kokku, Nad nägid seda kommentaari. Siis mõtlesid, et. Oot, siis hakkab Ruto ära minema, Nagu et mina ei ole näinud.
Õpetaja: Seal ei olnud öeldud ka Kes selle korda peaks tegema, et see oli niuke veits?
Õpetaja: Ee, kui ma ära läksin, siis ta seal endiselt oli
Õpetaja: nii. Ee, aga lähme edasi. Ee, mis meil on siis tehtud on? Ee, see Niukene Happy Bath Miinus väikse võlaga on ju, et ee, veel oleks vaja edasi teha.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on Catchblock Catchblock töötab jälle täpselt samamoodi, et kõigepealt on meil vaja mingisugust muutujat.
Õpetaja: Tema ise pakub siin selle muutuja õnneks, Kontrollitühik Tuleb säte, pakub niukest. Ee, peavad olema täpselt siin. Keskel Ee pakub, Aga mulle meeldib pigem
Õpetaja: error. Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: see on niimoodi. Kui saadad, see on nagu kihvt sõnum.
Õpetaja: Kui mina saadan sõnumi ja saan vastuse siis kukunki.
Õpetaja: Kui ma saan staatusega nelisada midagi või viissada, see tähendab, et on viga, siis käivitatakse see blokk. Need mõlemad korraga ei saa käivituda. Nad on teine teist välistavad. See on If Else
Õpetaja: If all Good Wen Else Error.
Õpetaja: Siin saab samamoodi teha. Kui me saaks ühele reale kirjutada, me edaspidi nii teeme, siis oleks väga tiptop. Siis me teeks niimoodi, et me kirjutaksime siia. Aga kui üle mitme koodi rea kirjutada, siis see sulgude vahel ei saa, Lihtsalt ei saa panna entreid,
Õpetaja: see ei ole nagu. Okei.
Õpetaja: Tal on vaja siis juba koodiplokki. See näide näitab ka tegelikult niimoodi. Vaata, Control tühik. Ta nagu näitab, et näed Reason Action ja võimaldab kirjutada
Õpetaja: mingeid koodiplokke, onju?
Õpetaja: Nii?
Õpetaja: No meie seda panemegi. Ma ütlen, et mulle tegelikult mulle üldse ei meeldi ei tea, Mulle meeldib teistmoodi teha.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, super super pupper.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, mis selle Erroriga saab? Teha? On see, et nüüd error.
Õpetaja: Error I Sees. On ka tegelikult. Aa, error on natukene mitmekihilisem.
Õpetaja: Ta ei ole Nii et kui me siin panime respons punkt data saime kohe vastuse kätte, Ma Korra panen siis selle ka ette, et missioon on see, et me saame Niukse sõnumi
Õpetaja: potentsiaalselt vale Kasutaja. Nimi Parool Status Kood on nelisada Kolm ja error. Kood on üks. Üks taask ütleb ka. Vaata, et vea vastuspäring. Kui vastuse Staatus on nelisada. Kolm
Õpetaja: ee, ja sõnumi Jason välja. Error Kood. Väärtus on üks üks. Nagu siin See näide, Siis kuvada message, peateade, peateade, kuva Selle pealt. Aga saa aru, kas olukord on Selline See on spetsiifiline olukord. Me tahame seda meie rakenduses arendaja teha. Lihtsalt väikse nagu selle error alertiga lahendada mis meil on juba olemas
Õpetaja: mõnel mõnele olukorrale vaja kuhugi suunata midagi või mida iganes, et kuidas. Front nüüd käitub, tuleb ka ära programmeerida.
Õpetaja: Selline
Õpetaja: ja et kuidas Meie front käitub. Vaata, sest, et, ee, Kui kasutaja paneb mingi pläusti sisse, siis ta ei saa User, Id, D ja ja rolli ma Panen mingi. Panen oma parooli valesti. Lihtsalt siis meie süsteem vastab vale kasutajanimi või parool.
Õpetaja: Noh, jumal, hoidkuge Niukene lahendus, mis sa ütleks ära Vaata, et
Õpetaja: õige kasutajanimi. Aga valeparood? See on Yes. Ee, on poolel teel.
Õpetaja: Ee, ei,
Õpetaja: ma olen näinud. Ee. Olen näinud mingit niukest nagu nalja. Vaata, et kui uue konto logimisel vaata, paned parooli ja siis nagu see on nagu nali. Vaata, et ütleb, et selline parool on Sellise kasutajanimega inimesel juba olemas. Vaata, et
Õpetaja: vegamisel Nagu et paned, on mingi muuki. Üks, kaks kolm ja naljaks. Jah,
Õpetaja: sisse logimisel, mitte regamisel. Oi, no see on küll. Nagu. See on nagu see, et kui sa tahaksid nagu scriptiga või millegiga mingi andmebaas, on sul kuskil olemas,
Õpetaja: Tahaksid nagu sellesse keskkonda sisse Niiöelda, siis sa oled juba tõesti poolel teel. Kui sa juba kasutaja nime seda vaadata, Aga see on vot, See on ka eraldi. See On ka jälle. Vaata, see on ka eraldi veakood. Selline kasutaja on juba olemas ja vaadataksegi
Õpetaja: regamisel see on Normaalne asi, et sul ei saa olla kaks sama emailiga kasutajat kui sisselogimiseks kasutatakse emaili,
Õpetaja: Noh, et siis, kui oleks kaks kasutajat registreeritud sama emailiga sisse. Kui nüüd kasutaja logib sisse, siis oleks küsimus, et kumb user nüüd siis sisse logis. Nagu kas nagu Juku või Juhan, Onju,
Õpetaja: Ee, et oleks nagu probleem.
Õpetaja: Ja see on andmebaasi tasandil Tegelikult juba ära kaitstud. Taast andmebaas tuuakse niukse skriptiga, kus öeldakse, et siin Veerus Peavad olema unikaalsed väärtused,
Õpetaja: et isegi kui programmiliselt või käsitsi, siis üritad sinna andmebaasi teha sissekannet, siis ta ütleb nagu
Õpetaja: ja tegelikult niuksed asja Sa kaitsed Sa Kaitsed selle põhimõtteliselt nii palju ära, kui saad. Sa teed selle kaitse. Selles mõttes, et sa peaksid. Tegelikult ju sa ei saa enam küll osta. Kui andmebaas viskab mingisuguse vea, siis sa tegelikult üldjuhul. Nagu ee, kasutajana ei jõua kui sa just progenud, aga tegelikult on see, et
Õpetaja: kui sa ikkagi lisad kasutajaid, sa pead nii programmiliselt vaatama, et kas sa saad lisada Ee, seda uut. Näiteks kasutajat. Ee, Mingi konkreetse emailiga. Sa pead vaatama, kas selline email on saadaval. Kui ei ole sa siis teavitud
Õpetaja: ei saa, onju
Õpetaja: Ee ja ja teistpidi Ma ütlen, et seal peab olema igal juhul Protection peal ka selles andmebaasis endas. Siin Veerus saavad olla emailid kordumatult.
Õpetaja: Siis on nagu see, Ee, nagu topelt kaitstud, et sa kaitsed Nagu selle vastu ka. Ärme unusta andmebaasid. On üks nagu selles mõttes ohtlik teema, et sinna saab ju tegelikult mistahes eskl lausega, kellel on ligipääs, saab ligi. Ju
Õpetaja: kui kellegil on juurdepääs Mingisugune andmebaasil, ta või mistahes esküveld skripte jooksutan selle aasta.
Õpetaja: Ee, tavaliselt adminid. Üsna palju toimetavadki. Tegelikult ka Scriptidega et luuakse mingisuguseid admin liideseid. Noh, beebileht põhimõtteliselt on ju, et, ee, admin saab mingeid asju teha Võimalikult sellised. Basic asjad on kõik ära kaetud, aga vahel harva midagi väga erilist vaja teha, siis me ei hakka arendust tegema. Sellepärast
Õpetaja: ma ei hakka tegema eraldi veebilehte, et mingi admin saab seda mugavalt nagu kuidagi teha Kui see on mingi erakorraline asi, saab skriptiga ära teha, Siis mingisugune
Õpetaja: andmebaasi. Haldur või kes iganes võib, siis nagu tiket. Võibolla nagu mitte nagu arendusmeeskonnale, vaid hoopis, ee, seal mingi Mingisugusele ee, database admiinile. Vaata, et palun ole hea tee. Midagi. Noh, kui ütleme kasutajal endal pole õigust, siis krüpto jooksutada kuskil teatud,
Õpetaja: okei, see selleks, et lähme edasi.
Õpetaja: Nii, Aa, nüüd See error on natukene võrreldes Aa responsiga Mitme kihilisem
Õpetaja: siin Errori enda sees on Niukene blokk nagu response
Õpetaja: Ja alles selle sees on tegelikult data. Vaadake, kui on Happy sõnum, siis Happy sõnumis on lihtsalt vähem Manti
Õpetaja: Error i puhul on igasugust veel juures üks asi on siis error respons, et ta on lihtsalt sügavam.
Õpetaja: Muud, midagi et niimoodi saab kätte. Põhimõtteliselt siis selle sõnumi siin, Nii,
Õpetaja: mis meil on siin öeldud, et ee. Tuleb visata veateade siin,
Õpetaja: kui vastuse Staatus on nelisada kolm kui
Õpetaja: ja error koodi Väärtus on üks üks. Nii me nüüd tegelikult. Enne kui me hakkame siin selle Erroriga nagu sisuliselt toimetama, et hetkel me viitame sellele, et Error Il on seal respons. Responsi osas on Tata, Vaata, on ju siis? Meil on seda vaja kuhugi, panna,
Õpetaja: et edaspidi saaks mugavalt. Ee, Meil on vaja teha põhimõtteliselt täpselt sama liigutus. Iga kord. Kui me saame mingisuguse objekti, siis meil on datablokis vaja ühte muutujat kuhu me Saame selle sisu ära panna, et meil oleks siin programmis mudel ka ees. Et mis? Mis me nüüd siis tegelikult saame? Vaata, et me Saame välja. Me saame niukse objekti. Kus on välja messager. Kood
Õpetaja: siis? Mis me teeksimegi? Ma ei tea, kas tänan selle lahti või mitte,
Õpetaja: No võib käsitsi ka kirjutada. Vahet pole, teeme vahepeal käsitsi, mis? Me võiksime panna selle asja selle objekti Nimeks nad siin. Muutujad selles, Ee, Siin Muutuja nime selles Ee, dokumentatsioonis ei ole selle. Peame ise välja mõtlema.
Õpetaja: Kui me panime selle, panime, siis see võiks olla.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd Siin on üks asi, millest ma pole rääkinud seda. Vaata, et, ee, heal Lapsel Mitu nime?
Õpetaja: Ee, üks asi, mida Code Reviews mitte kunagi Ei maksa hakata vaidlema mingi kuradi nimede pärast.
Õpetaja: Ee, teed sina mingi meetodi nime Teed Mingi muutuja nime. Sinu Arvates on väga, väga fine.
Õpetaja: Ja siis läheb Code Review Sse. Ja siis, kui tuleb Niuke tagasiside, et. Kuule, ma ei tea. See meetodi nimi võiks olla kuidagi selline Või muutuja nimi, et on asjad. Ee, mille üle? Nagu, ee. Ütleme Nii et need sõjad, mis sa valid, Ee, et kui sa, tahad Code Review Challenge Ida, et minu variant sobib ka. Tuleb olla kindlasti hästi läbi mõeldud. Ja pigem alguses seda mitte teha, et isegi siis, Kui te arvate, et teil on õigus, siis teil ikkagi ilmselt ei ole veel nii palju kogemust,
Õpetaja: et saada asjadest aru, Võibolla detailsemalt, aga Kui juhul, kui te ikkagi seda arvate, siis loomulikult kõike võib teha. Arutluse vormis on kõik, mis? Kuidas see minu oma on halvem siis Või või mis iganes saab seda arutada ka, niimoodi onju, et miks? Miks see, nagu minu oma? Kuidas nad erinevad kui sa ei saa, aru. Vaata, et nagu, et mis see päris erinevus on, saad ka niimoodi arutleda seda asja, et kas siis
Õpetaja: seal päriselt on mingit erinevust või mitte, onju Võibolla siis ongi.
Õpetaja: Aga üks asi, mille pärast ei ole, ei ole mõtet hakata saagima, on meetodi nimel, et muutuja, nimed Ja niuksed asjad, et siin on ikka nagu. Vaata, et, ee. No ma ei tea. Ee. Kellele meeldib musta värvi auto, kellele meeldib roosa No, kes sind mõistab nüüd hukka inimese, kellele meeldib roosa auto. Nagu naisterahvastele meeldibki onju?
Õpetaja: Meeldib roosa auto Vaata ega? Siis ta kuidagi teistsugune ei ole. Võibolla ta on natuke teistsugune kuidagi.
Õpetaja: Ee, et ee. Selles mõttes, et paljud asjad on maitse asi
Õpetaja: Maitse asi on ka ee, et kui ma saaks muud asja nagu ära, siis ma arvan, et minu oma on ka. Okei,
Õpetaja: Jumal, minuga. On täpselt vahet pole, vahet pole tegelikult
Õpetaja: savi. Lähme, Edasi töö liigub. Ee, pole seda vaja. Ee, et niukses kohas mitte kunagi tundlik olla. Ja Ja siin ka kui Mina kirjutan koodi. Ma mõtlen, siit ma iga kord. Ma ei vaata kunagi. Ma ei vaata oma eelmist lahendust, Ma ei, ma ei mäletagi Isegi kuidas me viimane kord tegime? Mul oli savi
Õpetaja: ja niikuinii. Iga kord uuesti. Iga kord jälle mõtlen neid nimesid ja asju uuesti ja, Ee, siin. Mõne asjaga on niimoodi, et võib teie mingisugust pakutud variant võib samahästi olla. Okei?
Õpetaja: Et nagu mõned asjad on nagu maitse asi
Õpetaja: Terrorespons oleks täpselt, see, mis mina, oleks ise siin pannud. Nii et selle pakkusite õigesti. Või Noh, kui võib nii öelda õigesti,
Õpetaja: mis väljad siin on? Siis kirjutame käsitsi. Siin on message.
Õpetaja: Päriselust. Mitte seda käsitsi teha. Ja lihtsalt. Kuna teil võibolla ei olnud käepärast seda message, Noh, Siin käib siis string. Me paneme lihtsalt tühjast ringi. See annab meile sellest mudelist märku. Ja teine on error kood
Õpetaja: ja tema on siis idee järgi number. Noh, paneme siis nulli. Nüüd on mudel ees. Olete nõus
Õpetaja: nüüd programmiliselt? Ma ei pea hakkama vaatama kui ma mingi fronti Siin teen, et et kui ma. Et mi. Mis mu potensiaal sealt sealt nüüd vastu tuleb.
Õpetaja: Nii lihtne see ongi, aga ma ütlen, päriselus oleks lihtsalt. Ee. See tuleb alati Copy Tes. Vägerist nagu. No mis Takes. There, et tuled ikka teed niimoodi?
Õpetaja: Noh, läks valesti. Nime Peab mõtlema ikka ise. Vaata, et oleks päris elus. Ma oleks teinud selle niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, alla ei jõudnud, Kus ta ei nõu magama.
Õpetaja: Oota, error Kood. Aa, siin vä.
Õpetaja: Seda seda koma mõtled või? See on. See on treeningkomma. Vaata, päris Jasonis. See ei ole lubatud. Ee, on see lubatud.
Õpetaja: Näete, siin on ka. Vaata, tegelikult. Noh, me võime kõik need siit ära võtta. Siit ei saa, onju? Sellepärast, et siin on eraldus,
Õpetaja: Siit ei saa ka ära võtta. On ju, et see eraldab kahte objekti.
Õpetaja: Aga siin seest saab. Ja siin lõpus saab ka Ee, aga
Õpetaja: Aga Jasonis ei saa. Jason on kohe katki ja ütleb ka treening oma Jasonis. E või?
Õpetaja: Ee, aga kui me kirjutame Scripti ennast, siis võib
Õpetaja: ja pigem isegi tasub jätta. Vaata, Sest et see on nagu kui ma tahan siia mingit välja panna, ma saan seda tublid ja Lets Go, Vaata, onju?
Õpetaja: Kuigi ma ei tea, see natuke. Võibolla siis silma riivab. Vaata, see. See treening, kui oma riivaga siin natukene isegi Riivab,
Õpetaja: kui ta tuleks tegelikult meile Niiöelda päriselt sealt Ee, läbi Svägeri, mis on meie koodibaasi pealt kirjutatud, siis siin ei oleks enam String. Lihtsalt seal on ees juba Niukene mudel. String ja null. Ja
Õpetaja: tuledki siia teed selle lihtsalt tühjaks ja ongi kõik onju Mudel on ees
Õpetaja: No võibolla jälle mingi väike ka. Ma vaatan, kas see ei tohiks neid ridu ära võtta. Linter Võibolla võtab. Ma loodan, et ei võta, Ee, minule meeldib nagu neid mitmekihilisi objekte.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tahaksin Error Sportsis saada messegile või Error koodile ligi, siis kuidas ma saaks talle ligi Kui ma koodis kirjutaksin,
Õpetaja: Kui ma kirjutaksin praegu, et ee, viitaksin sellele, kuidas ma saaksinile ligi?
Õpetaja: Noh, kohe saabki seda teha. Ei, kes Vaata, et siis, saame mõelda, mis me tahame nüüd teha, on on see, et näete see sama asi, Vaata, mis niiöelda. Siis kustutame korra ära. Et me tahame öelda nüüd, et. Ee, palun. See error
Õpetaja: respons.
Õpetaja: Ütleme, et nüüd, mis sisse meil tuleb. Meil tuleb kogu Error Error. Seal on response objekt.
Õpetaja: Punkt data.
Õpetaja: Vot niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma ei saa aru miks ma ei saa tema errorist aru. Ta nagu justkui viitab, et,
Õpetaja: miks umbes pont seal on?
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et see siin. Või sellepärast, et see error on mitme kihiline.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma. Näit. Ma kas ma vist Pean näitama. Ta vist ei saa aru. Vaata muidu ennem sellest.
Õpetaja: See tavaline respons on lihtsalt struktuurilt lamedam.
Õpetaja: Seal sees ongi. Kohe data ja Nii edasi. Error ei ole. Lame Erroris ei ole kohe tata,
Õpetaja: Vaid erroris on alamobjekt. Sponsor Sponsises on data,
Õpetaja: et seal on, ta on Lihtsalt mitmekihilisem. Kui ma joonistaksin selle sama asja siia Põhimõtteliselt, siis Error. Oleks umbes Mingi Selline
Õpetaja: error.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd siin tuleb response
Õpetaja: mis on Omakorda objekt. Kus sees on? Data,
Õpetaja: mis on? Ütleme siis omakorda Objekt. Mis kand on siis see sama, mis on siin Saate aru, ta on kihilisem.
Õpetaja: Aga Tavaline see respons, mis see on?
Õpetaja: See on põhimõtteliselt ainult see osa siin
Õpetaja: saate aru, nad on erinevad. Error on mitmekihilisem
Õpetaja: Responsi Sees on kohe Data Error I sees on kõigepealt respons ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Aga ma ei saa hästi aru sellest joonest,
Õpetaja: ma küsin korra selle kohta ka Vaatame. Kas seda kopida saab. Kuidagi ka. Või
Õpetaja: ma ütlen, ma korra ütlen, aga lihtsalt ütlen, kui ma viitan tata Blokile.
Õpetaja: Aga ma viitan ju sellele sildikesele, Mis on siin.
Õpetaja: Ee, nii et ma. Ma võtan kogu selle asja ette, ni sellisel kujul ka Ja Siis ma annan talle ette, et, ee, saan ides
Õpetaja: sellise hoiatuse. Ma ei saa aru nagu. Kas ma teen midagi valesti. Ee, või Siis see Warning on bullshit.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, mida Claudia ütleb. No, kui mõnus on niimoodi töötada nagu.
Õpetaja: No vaatame,
Õpetaja: see on ju mingisugune. Ütleb idea, et usalda mind. See on õige tüüp ja hoiatus kaob. Ei, mind ei huvita see hoiatus. Siis sellisel juhul
Õpetaja: põhimõtteliselt põhimõtteliselt nagu ise, nagu ei usalda. Vaata, et et sa võid panna sellist objekti selle asja sisse. Noh, ma olen kogu aeg seda teinud, nii et see asi Nagu ei ole probleem.
Õpetaja: See on lihtsalt nagu ta ei ole tema. Ei ole kindel, et kas see asi, mis sealt tuleb, datast, sobib Täpselt sellise mudeliga kokku, mis me oleme defineerinud. Saate aru? Kui ma võtaksin praegult selle osa, maha siis ta ei peaks üldse midagi vinguma.
Õpetaja: Lähed seda? Noh, nüüd ma ei ole ette öelnud. Vaata, et milline see errorespons objekt on.
Õpetaja: See on uus asi Varasemalt pole seda olnud,
Õpetaja: Kui mul on lihtsalt, et ei. Siin on üks muuta ja topi sinna asju sisse, siis mis iganes sealt tuleb, küll see sobib. Noh, Sest ma ei ole ära defineerinud nagu seda mudelit. Aga kui mul on mudel defineeritud, siis ta justkui annab nagu hoiatust. Huvitav, et tal Ei ole seda sama muret nagu siin.
Õpetaja: Nagu tavalist responsi. On nagu igati tip Top toppida nagu siia mudelisse, et siit ta võtab eelduse, et jah, mul on see asi. Õige. Aga nüüd Erroriga. Ta järsku mõtleb, et kus sa ikkagi tead. Võibolla ta mõtleb, et ta peaks tulema. Standard error, kus on viis välja,
Õpetaja: aga neli välja Vist on tegelikult standard. Erroris.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis serverid tagastavad vaikimisi, aga ühesõnaga niukest jama Et ma nagu kirjutan koodi juurde, et idele nagu mingeid märku anda, et ma seda joont ei näe. Siis on nagu ei huvita. Absoluutselt
Õpetaja: Ee, no põhimõtteliselt. Nüüd saab vaadata, kas see nagu töötab ka. No ma võin korra teha. Tähendab, nüüd on vaja seda, et
Õpetaja: minul vaikimisi Kogu aeg. Ee, vastab. Stoplight sellele positiivselt.
Õpetaja: Kuidas siis saab proovida? Vaata, et kas see asi töötab. Ma võin korra panna siia. See on Kaas vaatamise koht. Kurat. Ee, alert.
Õpetaja: Ee, alert. Ma ütlen sest, et error on tegelikult java Scripti objekt on ju?
Õpetaja: Ma Ütlen, et ole hea. Tee. See lihtsalt. String iks.
Õpetaja: Copy. Paste Teda me sealt ei saa, aga tühja temast. Aga vähemalt siis.
Õpetaja: Aa, korra näeb. Tegelikult teeme Selle natukene edasi Teeme. Selle message osa. Ära ka vaata. Siis. Aa, enne kui me seda proovime, teeme nüüd selle ülejäänud osa ära
Õpetaja: taaskis On öeldud nüüd, et mis peab nüüd juhtuma, on see, et kui staatus on ee,
Õpetaja: staatus on nelisada kolm ja väärtus on üks üks,
Õpetaja: Siis kuvada, mis iganes on, message väljal. Noh, seda me otse ei taha koodi sisse kirjutada, vaid siis tuleb backend ist.
Õpetaja: Okei, no mis Ma kirjutan siia. Ärge tee mulle. Hoidke kood ees, Mis ma kirjutan siia.
Õpetaja: If on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, if.
Õpetaja: Nüüd status quo see. On tegelikult ka selle Errori küljes olemas.
Õpetaja: Kui ma ütlen Error punkt Response punkt, mis ma siit võtan.
Õpetaja: Staatus on number nüüd, kui see, mis ma Siia kirjutan
Õpetaja: kolmikut märki. Miks tüüpi? Vaatame ka.
Õpetaja: Ütleme, et kui see on nelisada, kolm
Õpetaja: ja Jason välja. Error kood, mis ma siis kirjutan Siia, kaks.
Õpetaja: Nüüd öelge, mille. Mis ma siia kirjutan,
Õpetaja: sest eesmärk on nüüd vaadata selle sõnumi
Õpetaja: Error. Kood väärtust, mis? Ma kirjutan siia,
Õpetaja: This Punkt, mis ma kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, siin eelneval real. Me paneme kogu selle vastuse siia.
Õpetaja: Siin on meil ette see siin selles muutujas. Ee, see info elab ja siin on meil mugavalt olemas ka. Tegelikult. Aa, mudel, et mis väljad seal sees on, Ja nüüd kui me, kui me Selles mõttes, et idee järgi. Mul on endiselt olemas see info nii selle Errori sees kui ka error responsi sees.
Õpetaja: Mõlema sees siit hästi pikalt saaks minna. Error Respons, Punkt Error. Message saaks ka kätte. Päriselt, seal objektil on Niukene väli. See Ju tuleb. Internetist on ju serverist, Aga meil on mugavam progeda selle asja vastu,
Õpetaja: sest et meil on kõik info olemas.
Õpetaja: Noh, ütleme, pakub, et siin on niuksed välja terrorkood Ja message, mis meid huvitab terve pool error kood.
Õpetaja: Ja me saame seda vaadata, et kui see võrdub võrdub millega, kui on üks üks, Üks
Õpetaja: nii nüüd. Control Shift enter. Vaata, me oleme If Real ja me oleme siin Infi, keskel. Teeme selle Control shift Enter teeb nagu
Õpetaja: tegi.
Õpetaja: Tegi nagu need loogilised hullud, vaid ta mentrite. Oleme kohe siin sees.
Õpetaja: Nüüd öeldakse, et siis peab tulema vea teade vale kasutajanimi parool, Mille me saame. Selle Message I seest.
Õpetaja: Seda peab siin kuvama, mäletate? Täida kõik väljad või? Teine variant? Vale kasutaja nimi parool.
Õpetaja: Okei, siis Mina küsin, mis ma nüüd siis siia kirjutan. No kuidas me viitame? Mis? Mis, härra Sõnumis? Sa räägid?
Õpetaja: Üleval Pool defineeritud, onju?
Õpetaja: Toimuv vastab tõele. See error message on ülevalt. Vaadake, kui klikid siia peale kontrolli kes ta Näitab, kus ma teda siin näen. Vaadake, Real viis selles Samas näitab, et Alert Error, error message. Error messed. Mäletate see reaktiivne komponent? Kui sisu on, siis näita,
Õpetaja: on ju ehk seal on seotud See data bloki ee muutujaga.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis täpselt seda me soovimegi teha. Me soovime lihtsalt Kus siin me andsime. Vaata, siin. Me tegime sealt Sama asja,
Õpetaja: et ee, kui ee. Kasutaja ei täitnud ära kõiki.
Õpetaja: Kui kasutaja vormil ei ole kõik korrektsed väljad täidetud, siis El see blokk käivitub eilse blokis. Ütles error message. Ta ei taha kõik väljad. Ja siis ta ju ilmus nähtavale. No nüüd on sama asi. Põhimõtteliselt ütleme This
Õpetaja: Punkt, error message.
Õpetaja: Anname talle uue sisu ühe võrdusmärgiga mis ma nüüd edasi kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Missioon on ju see, et nüüd tuleb võtta mis Iganes on siin väärtus, mis? Ma kirjutan. Siia.
Õpetaja: This. Message vä ei sobi this. Proovime message. Message pole error message Noh iseendaga panna võrduma Vist ei ole ka väga point I.
Õpetaja: No kus on kogu minu info Praeguseks etapiks? Siin Selles skoobis error responsi sees, onju?
Õpetaja: See ongi mõeldud, et nüüd, kus see kõik on seal olemas, siis ma saan ainult viidata nendele väljadele, mida ma arvan, et seal peaks sees olema, onju? Ütlen Error response
Õpetaja: samamoodi, nagu me siit Vaatasime Error responsi seest. Error koodi
Õpetaja: ütles, et Vaata, võta sealt. See on nagu see, Vaata, Kui ma vaatan Highlight in selle siis näete. Kuidas see siin on. Niimoodi, roheline. Sa viitad sellele väljale objektis.
Õpetaja: Nüüd me ei taha error error koodile viidata. Vaid tahame viidata Hoopis message Le.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. See garanteerib ju, et kui tuleb error olukord, siis Alert tuleb
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et siin on sisu. See sisu on seal üleval
Õpetaja: Valer terrorisse edastatud. Kõik reaktiivselt näitab.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on küsimus, et, ee, et kuidas siis, nagu me saaksime seda asja proovida, et see päriselt ka töötab.
Õpetaja: Ee, sellepärast, et vaikimisi tagastab see meie server koguaeg. Admin Ee Vabandust, user Id, üks ja Admin
Õpetaja: iga kord, kui me üritame sisse logida. Stoplight lihtsalt vastab ühte sama vastust, et.
Õpetaja: Kuule, et, ee. Noh, ma saan siia sisse,
Õpetaja: näete Praegult tema kogu aeg vastab. Ee, mida iganes. Mina panen siis vaikimisi Ta saadab mulle kogu aeg seda vastust. Kakssada ja okei,
Õpetaja: ee, ei, me Ei, pea vastust muutma.
Õpetaja: Ee, siia Siis, kui me saadame sõnumi Stoplight Ile,
Õpetaja: siis, ee, Meil on võimalik informatsiooni sõnumis anda kolmes kohas Urlis. Url on informatsioon. Palun anna mulle midagi. Mingi ressurss.
Õpetaja: Aa, siis on Urli parameetrid, muidugi. Noh, see on osa urlist. Siis on Aa, Jason, me saame mingi. Me saame mingisuguse Body või faili kaasa panna. Aga üks asi on veel sõnumitel ka. Seal käib ka kaasas selline Sektsioon nagu Heeder päis.
Õpetaja: See on jälle nagu nähtamatu osa. Vaata, aga ta on metainfona olemas.
Õpetaja: Nüüd nemad on teinud Niimoodi ma panen esiteks selle, et ma tahan seda. Mitte C Urlis, vaid Ma tahan hoopis Request I.
Õpetaja: Näete, siin on niukene asi, nagu et sõnumiga pannakse kaasa Asi Headers. Vaata, me oleme seda juba oleme teinud. Param
Õpetaja: siin on nagu meie sõnum. Nagu. Vaata ennem, meil oli mingi A ja B W, onju? Me saame öelda, et Headers ja mina saan öelda, kui ma siin näiteks saan proovida, et Ei, mina tahan saada error vastust Nelisada, kolm ja example error.
Õpetaja: Siis vaadake, kui sina paned error sisse Niukse asja.
Õpetaja: Kood nelisada, kolm ja error kood. Siis tema saadabki täpselt sellise vastuse.
Õpetaja: No sõnumi saatmisel. Saame teda mudida, et. Kuule, ole hea.
Õpetaja: Näed siin, Kus meil. Kus Meie saame seda teha? Vaata, kus on Params
Õpetaja: See asi on konfigobjekti sees. Mäletate Control B.
Õpetaja: Kogu See asi on Konflik Objekt siin. Oleme ainult Kasutanud. Paramsit,
Õpetaja: aga ma saan siia panna hoopis ka headers
Õpetaja: neid. Saab mitu olla. Kool on loogilised sulud
Õpetaja: Ja tema nüüd ütleb. Vaata, et mina pean ainult ütlema, nagu, et on Niukene. Ee, väline Nagu
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd siia stringina. Saan Mina öelda nagu, et. Kuule, ole hea,
Õpetaja: ma annan kohe teile selle kogu selle selle koodi osa nagu ise, et pane. Kui ma mina saadan niimoodi headerist kaasa Informatsiooni.
Õpetaja: Nelisada, kolm ja Example Error. Müüd sõnumit kaasa, pannes See info läheb ka kaasa Ja siis. Stoplight vastab mulle täpselt selle vastusega, mida mina preferin. Ma teen niimoodi, et ma tõmban selle kokku. Tehke seda teie ka, kes tahate.
Õpetaja: Ma kopin selle asja niimoodi. Näed tee samamoodi. Lihtsalt tehke siniseks. Ja osa pärast
Õpetaja: mina panen selle näiteks praegu Chat I.
Õpetaja: Ma panen praegu generali alla pärast. Võibolla kustutan selle ära. Võibolla jätab ka. Vahet pole, ma panen kogu selle asja sulgede Karvadega, kes tahab,
Õpetaja: saab võtta selle või saate varsti järgi ka tulla.
Õpetaja: Marten, Mäge mägi.
Õpetaja: See On see üks A Täht on jäänud ette. Vaata, see on see. Kui mingi naine paneb mingi,
Õpetaja: kirjutab Facebookis, ja unustab lahti akna ja mingi üks A on, siis mõtleb mine pekki Mis siit tuleb? Nagu tund aega, kirjutab juba nagu
Õpetaja: midagi head. Siit ei tule.
Õpetaja: Nii, no Proovime nüüd, et kui ma saadan selle sõnumi, Minul on ära progetud. Ju Meil on ära blogetud, et Er on mess. Et saab ju uue sisu, on ju? Näed siin?
Õpetaja: Kohe Võibolla Teeme korrabougimist ka. Vaata, ma näitan, kuidas saab. Aa, its. Not fantastic but it works. Ee. Saab hakkama kaugimisega.
Õpetaja: Oi, kurat, see ei ole Mahl, see on ju?
Õpetaja: Kas paus ei peaks olema üldse ka? Kohe vist tuleb paus ka. Onju Kannujook. Kas sa näed siin
Õpetaja: jänese auk see oli.
Õpetaja: Vaatame nüüd korra, kas see asi töötab? Ee, seda koodi järgi. Ma ütleks, et see peaks töötama. Pole vahet, mida ma siia Kirjutan,
Õpetaja: kui ma võtan. Login.
Õpetaja: Nüüd vaatame korra, mis taustal juhtub. Ma teen korra. Refresh. On ju Refresh. Panen inspect
Õpetaja: Ma tulen Network I alla vaatan. Korra. Ma saadan selle sama sõnumi uuesti.
Õpetaja: Sõnum läheb teele. Aga nüüd näitab, et oma sõnum on punane staatus on nelisada, kolm on nii?
Õpetaja: Kui ma lähen selle peale,
Õpetaja: siis ma saan vaadata, et respons oli niimoodi vale. Kasutajanimi juba rool. Kui ma lähen Headersi juurde, Siis ma saan veel natuke rohkem informatsiooni.
Õpetaja: Kuskil peaks olema ka Request. Headers.
Õpetaja: Näete, Request läks teele ja läks kaasa. Niukene. Ee, parameeter. Nagu Sellise väärtusega
Õpetaja: sedaviisi. Stoplight jääb, et ta vastaks mulle teistmoodi.
Õpetaja: Kas Te saate enamvähem? Aru? Vaata, see ei ole nüüd päris server. Veel ei Tööta see ta ei saanud. Ma võin panna siia, mida iganes. Mul ei ole õigeid ega valet paroole praegu seisus, vaid Stop Light lihtsalt Vastab nii, nagu mina ütlen, et Kuule, vasta mulle niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Päris niita. Jah,
Õpetaja: et seda saab ajutiselt, et selles mõttes, et kuidas ma vanasti Nägin copy Based. Keegi võtab, onju?
Õpetaja: Nii? Ee, et kuidas ma vahel näen, et on mingi copy based imine toimunud on on see, et me praegu oma õppeprojektis kasutame seda,
Õpetaja: et. Nagu. Et. Ee. Anna mulle mingi vastus. Kui sa lähed pärast enda serveri, ega ta ei tee Midagi meil pole ära programmeeritud enda back and server, et kui tuleb eetris, siis see preföör. Mida iganes, siis tee midagi.
Õpetaja: Stop Light is On see ära programmeeritud. Ja kui ma olen näinud nagu teie, niiöelda ee, projektikoodides seda perfööri niimoodi täpselt samal kujul, siis ma tean, et Aa, nad tulid lihtsalt kuskilt. Ja
Õpetaja: sealt see tuli. Siis ma olen küsinud Ka Vahel on lihvlaused veel. Ees, Vaata et me nagu annaks ühte ja teist.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd suures pildis. See töötab, välja Arvatud ee navigatsioon.
Õpetaja: Aga mina juba tunnen, et. Ee. Ma tahaks teha kogu seda asja nüüd nagu uuesti. Aga natukene teistmoodi.
Õpetaja: Me saaks copy based. Me saaksime nüüd teha niimoodi ka, et me hakkame neid tegema eraldi meetoditeks Ja tõstame neid kohte ja nii edasi. Aga tegelikult, see lööb pea nii sassi.
Õpetaja: Ee, see ei ole loetav kood.
Õpetaja: Ükski meetod ei peaks tegelikult olema pikem, kui. No ütleme. Noh, näiteks kakskümmend rida välja arvutada teeb mingit üli spetsiifilist asja
Õpetaja: Kui sul on kood juba nii pikk, Siis Siin on mingisugused loogilised lõigud
Õpetaja: ja need loogilised lõigud tuleks teha nimeliseks koodilõiguks, mida me kutsume välja. Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: me saaksime siit ekstraktida, no Ma idee järgi näitan. Noh, me saaksime teha niimoodi. Näiteks et see osa. Ma. Ma näitan. Ma teen kommitti. Ära Vaata, me niikuinii. Paneme tuimelt uuesti, et saaksite. Võttes ta aru, et tegelt see lõpptulemus oleks niikuinii see sama.
Õpetaja: Ee, teen comiti ära. Ee, ma võin bussi ka teha, kui keegi tahab järgi tulla. Aga me niikuinii kohe kustutame ära ja hakkame tegema seda asja natuke. Uuesti,
Õpetaja: et, ee, ma saaksin teha Niimoodi, et näiteks see siin. See osa tegelikult
Õpetaja: koos ülejäänud osaga. Mis on veel To Do on teha selle asja Võiks öelda, et on, Miks me saame ju vastuse
Õpetaja: saame?
Õpetaja: Me teeme erinevaid asju. Me ei saa lihtsalt öelda, mida ta teeb. Me paneme asju. Me navigeerime kuskile mujale,
Õpetaja: Siis me ei tahaks panna meetodi nimesse, et ma ei tea mingi safe data to Session storage. No see meetodi nimi oleks Pikk,
Õpetaja: Aga mis me tahame teha? Idee järgi on, see, et oleks controlört M.
Õpetaja: Ekstrakt Top level Üks Samm alla. Ärge tehke seda seal pole mõtet siia. Ma paneks lihtsalt login ja sponsor.
Õpetaja: Nii aitan entreid.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd ei ole isegi vaja. Vaata, kas mitu rida koodi on praegult siin selle koodiploki sees. Siin üks koodirida.
Õpetaja: Kui see on üks koodirida, siis ma isegi ei peaks panema seda loogiliste sulgude sisse, vaid ta saaks kohe niimoodi jääda.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, vend. Blokk näeks Niukene välja. Nüüd see asi oleks. Siin. Pole ka veel päris lõplik. Siin on üks osa veel puudu. See oleks
Õpetaja: Selle asja nimi oleks Handle Log in
Õpetaja: error. Näiteks kas respons panna või Mitte natuke. Maitse asi nii.
Õpetaja: Ja see oleks ka jälle see tegelikult lihtsalt ühel real.
Õpetaja: Noh, nüüd see asi siin. Sõnumi saatmine.
Õpetaja: Ma tegelikult ei tahaks, et see üldse siin on,
Õpetaja: Ma tegelikult tahaks, et mul oleks üks eraldi kaust
Õpetaja: service.
Õpetaja: Ma paneks mitmeses, kuna teised on siin ka mitmeses services.
Õpetaja: Ma tahaks, et mul oleks Siin üks eraldi java script fail.
Õpetaja: Ee, mille nimi oleks, siis? Mis? Ta hakkab loo kinni tegema Paneks. Selle nimeks. See on kõik Ainult vaatamise kohta. Ärge tehke midagi
Õpetaja: siin. Ma Sooviksin, et. Ee, seda siin on. Ja voe asjad, mida on võimalik ee käivitada lause juures Export Default. Ja mina sooviksin, et see osa siin, kõik see siin.
Õpetaja: Headers, bla, bla, bla.
Õpetaja: Ma sooviks, et kogu see koodilõik,
Õpetaja: mis on Kuni siiamaani sõnumi saatmine.
Õpetaja: Ma sooviksin, et see tegelikult oleks üldse siin, Et oleks eraldi meetod.
Õpetaja: Mulle meeldib siin hästi tehniliselt teha. Ee, send Get Login Request Niukene Meetod oleks siin sees, oleks see asi.
Õpetaja: Nii.
Õpetaja: Ja siis, kui ma kutsun seda välja, siis see näeks välja niimoodi Selle mudru asemel. Mis siin on
Õpetaja: selle mudru aseme, mis siin on? Ma lihtsalt sooviks näha niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Login Service punkt request.
Õpetaja: Ahah, sinu retöörne on puudu.
Õpetaja: Nii Selgitan seda pärast ka.
Õpetaja: Vot kui ma loeks juba niimoodi koodi, siis juba oleks nagu normaalne reseterror. Message before
Õpetaja: ja siis on see, et kui kõik läheb hästi, mis ta niimoodi lilla on?
Õpetaja: Ee,
Õpetaja: mis ta nagu, ee, peaks olema nagu sinist värvi No ma ei ole harjunud. Ma ei saa aru, vahet pole. Ee. Käivitab ühemeetodid. Võibolla värvid on vahepeal muutuvad ka
Õpetaja: ja peaks. Olema. Näed, sest et See siin. Ma korra vaatan. Korra. Mis nende vahe on?
Õpetaja: Mis on selle vahe?
Õpetaja: See, et on meetodis? Ta on selle Wen Block I sees. Sellepärast ma pakun. Ee, kas te saate mõttest aru? Vaata, et
Õpetaja: see kood oleks juba raamat, mis räägib midagi. Ta räägib mulle loo. Kõigepealt resetime mingi error message. Kui kõik väljad on täidetud, saadame sõnumi. Kui kõik läheb hästi, siis Handl, Ime seda kui läheb halvasti
Õpetaja: els, Täida kõik välja.
Õpetaja: Vot niimoodi tahaks koodi lugeda. Kui ma nüüd teen siin Roll back.
Õpetaja: No kui keegi tuleb ütlema, siis alati on seda Eriti kirjutab mingi pika loogika välja. Ifid ja asjad.
Õpetaja: Tükeldame siis peale seda meetodit, eks? Ära Niimoodi ekstraktides tükeldame. Ära. Alati on keegi, kes Ütleb, et minu meelest niimoodi, enne. Kuidas oli palju parem? Jah, me just kirjutasime Selle Mõttelõng on koos jah, ifid asjad. Kõik võrdlused mis sa teed on loetav
Õpetaja: aga proovi panna nüüd ennast sellesse mindset I, et lihtsalt sa teed mingit suurt projekti ja sa satud lihtsalt selle koodilõigu peale. Siis vaatad. Mingi on mingisugune staff seal. Lihtsalt siis see ei ole enam nii loogiline. See kood on loetav,
Õpetaja: teine kord, mitte Nii väga, et. Noh, kui ma teen selle Rolbacki ära, siin,
Õpetaja: teeme mõlemad Roll Backi. Ära Näed Roll Back, Rol, Back, Roll Back
Õpetaja: Noh, Et kui keegi tahab öelda tõesti, et tema esimesel korral tuleks peale ja oleks Super Excited
Õpetaja: Ee, näha seda koodi siin,
Õpetaja: siis ee, jah, Siis ma võiks ka öelda. Mina, mina lihtsalt. Ee, Kus on mul see avaldus lahkun?
Õpetaja: Ma ei viitsi niimoodi, saate aru, onju? Kood peab olema loetav. Mis on meetod? Meetod on imeline koodilõik. Seal ongi see põhiväärtus nimeline koodilõik.
Õpetaja: Kui te kirjutate mingisugust asja, hakatakse kommentaare kirjutama, et Et, ee, näiteks niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, pannakse peale. Näiteks, et, ee. See saadab sõnumi.
Õpetaja: See, ee, hand Ib vastust edukat vastust, Kui niimoodi teeks nagu neid.
Õpetaja: Jah, see handlib.
Õpetaja: Kui tuleb nelisada, kuni viissada status.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui hakkad juba kirjutama neid kommentaare, siis nagu. Lihtsalt vormista need koodilõigud
Õpetaja: meetoditeks, Ja mõtlen, kui võimalikult lühikene nimi, mis peegeldab seda kommentaari, ongi kõik olemas.
Õpetaja: Davai, lähme teeme nüüd ee selle Lunch I ära. Lunch I pausi
Õpetaja: või ma küsin jah, et, ee. Kui sa Highlight Id mingisuguse rehase all. Lihtsalt nii nagu niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: kui sa tahad midagi ekstraktida või midagi teha Siin on.
Õpetaja: Toon, mis? Mis ta ära värvib.
Õpetaja: No ma pean korra vaatama. Ma vist ei suuda niimoodi kirja kirja pildis Seda asja isegi on see värv vaata,
Õpetaja: loodus.
Õpetaja: Ma ei oska seda maha. Lähed ära, Spordid on Siit saan, siis
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea võibolla seda kunagi ma olen näinud.
Õpetaja: Aitäh, just.
Õpetaja: No vale see.
Õpetaja: Sul on kuskilt midagi enneemblemata.
Õpetaja: Ma ei saa vaadata praegu. Ma ei saa seda Ma näen, et vastus tuleb õige. R poolt tuleb õige.
Õpetaja: Ee, tee selle peale.
Õpetaja: Puhta kõhu ja ristis Saad siis, kui Yes,
Õpetaja: sa võid seal sadu sõnumeid näha Aga vaadata tahad ainult ühe kohta?
Õpetaja: Paljud sellised
Õpetaja: tehnilised asjad. Ma ei tea, kohe. Sellepärast ongi, et sa viibisid. Jah, nendest asjadest nii kiiresti, et. Noh,
Õpetaja: kuidagi vaadates lihtsalt tuleb kuidagi naerma ja. Ja said ise koht kus sa küsid Ja, no ma saan Jah,
Õpetaja: ma veel teada.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: tere, püüame. Esmaspäev on juba see Kusaž.
Õpetaja: Mhm, just, jah.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: ja võta selle. Kinni
Õpetaja: just.
Õpetaja: Aa,
Õpetaja: üheksakümmend.
Õpetaja: Ma Ei tea, kas
Õpetaja: vastu jälle lahti
Õpetaja: kõik rallid.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: jah,
Õpetaja: ee. Kas kõige lõpus? Ee, Ma pean korra vaatama. Oota mul on siin mingid Lahtised asjad, mida ma ei taha. Vaatan, mis siin toimub
Õpetaja: ja ma olen praegult selle ära kommit. Ind
Õpetaja: aa tea, aga ma ei ole Push Inud. Sorry.
Õpetaja: Ee, po. Pool võrrandast.
Õpetaja: Ja saad proovida kohe. Ma ütlen, Ee, põhimõtteliselt oikur. Ma ei pannud pausile. Nüüd ma panenegi pausile Rekordimise
Õpetaja: Natukene vähemaks. Seda rekordid.
Õpetaja: Kas keegi proovis? Ee, ka töötas töödand?
Õpetaja: Em, Ee, ma arvan, et ee, See on selles mõttes väärtuslik, ka Et, ee, teha meil üks väikene. Nagu
Õpetaja: me teeme selle taas ka uuesti. Ka palju kiiremad, mis me alles jätame, on see objektid nüüd Pole mõtet nagu uuesti Trade, et teeme puhtalt. Lihtsalt siis selle osa. Mis on selle põhimõtteliselt selle If I sees siin. Kõik teeme niiöelda uuesti.
Õpetaja: Mhmh, nii. Kas võib alustada kõigi vaatest?
Õpetaja: Okei, kustutame ära nüüd. Kogu selle ifi sisu, aga mitte ifja ennast
Õpetaja: kuusteist kuni video
Õpetaja: põhimõtteliselt Lihtsalt, Ee. Noh, ma võin vaadata halvasti. Mis? Ta oli siis? Kuuskümmend kuus, kuusteist vä. Aa, kuusteist. Hakkame siit niimoodi tulema, siis läheb väga Halvaks see asi.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: no tegelikult, ega seda. Oota sealt. Te saate seda ka Kasutada Vaata et kui näiteks minna mõne mõnele asjale, millel, on oma skoop. Näe, tal hakkab siitoskoop. Siis ta näitab niukse joonena ka, et põhimõtteliselt lihtsalt võib vastupidi teha ka teinekord, et hakkad siit Elsist pihta ja tuled näiteks niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: nüüd, Aa. Plaanis on siis teha niimoodi, et, ee, me tõesti hakkame kutsuma sõnumisse saatmise osa niiöelda välja. Ee, selles kohas, kus, Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, eraldi failist, et Las korra see jääb siia. Võib ühe kommentaari panna, et ta mingi selle punase asja siit ära. Kaotaks mingi kommentaari märgi kas või siis ta läheb punane eest ära.
Õpetaja: Nüüd teeme nii nagu Ee Mina ennem tegin Source kataloogi alla. Tehke Niukene Catalogu Services. Mul Ta on endiselt siin alles
Õpetaja: parem. Klõps, New Directori ja siis Service Sees.
Õpetaja: Mina ei saa seda, teha, sest. Vaata, mul on juba olemas.
Õpetaja: Nüüd me tahame siia sisse teha Javascripti faili,
Õpetaja: et Service is peal ka veel omakorda parem klõps
Õpetaja: Pange siis kindlasti. Mitmuses on ju? Te saate ka, veel kui vajaks ühte F. Kuus või mis iganes,
Õpetaja: parem. Klõps ja ee, siia fail Aa, jaa, Script File on ka. Siis ta paneb selle lõpu ise meie eest ära,
Õpetaja: Jaoscript File ja paneme selle nimeks siis login Service
Õpetaja: Nüüd, Aa, päris rakenduses, siis tegelikult hakkavad tulema teemade kauta. Service, Kui sul on näiteks mingid linnaandmed Kas Lisad, Soovid dropdown i igasuguseid. Asju Vaata, siis see võiks olla City Service
Õpetaja: Kui sul on näiteks mingid Aa tellimused. Oletame, et on mingi orders
Õpetaja: Kõik, asjad, mis sulle nagu mis sulle tekivad. Niiöelda eraldi klassid. Vaata, kus käivad kõik orderitega seotud, siis samamoodi, nagu et kõik teenused mis lähevad kuidagi orderite pihta et Anna mulle orderid. Kustuta order Muude order. Anna üks order Anna mitu ja nii edasi, on ju?
Õpetaja: Siis kujutage ette, et selle jaoks võiks olla eraldi kaust. Order
Õpetaja: Ee, Orders Service või Order Service vastavad maitsele. Kas mitmuses või mitte, Service ise on Juba Ainsuses on ju No siin väga kindlat reeglit pole, et me ei tee nüüd iga sõnumi jaoks iga sõn. Praegu tuleb loogil Service ja tulebki ainult üks sõnum Sinna see loginn,
Õpetaja: et sinna ei tule. Võibolla mitmeid. Ee, niiöelda. Ee sõnumite saatmise kohti niiöelda Aa, aga nagu päris rakenduses pigem siis on Nagu see, et sa jagad asja nagu valdkondadeks.
Õpetaja: Kujutad ette, et tal on mingid erinevad aa infoühikud seal Aa enda arvuti või tarvis selles projektis. Mida te tahate kätte saada, siis te nagu veits jagate neid niimoodi laiali. Nii Login Service
Õpetaja: tahab teeks.
Õpetaja: Pead vajutama õigesse kohta ja Ja kataloog. Aga kas ma pean Palju kataloog?
Õpetaja: Ei, kataloogil ei ole formaati. No kui sa lähed lihtsalt source i alla. Lihtsalt paned parem Klõps New direktori.
Õpetaja: Aa, Jah, et tal nagu informaati ei ole.
Õpetaja: Botomline on see, et me tahame teha siis ühte Jaovascripti faili siia sisse, Mille nimi on? Suure tähega mentorite.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tema on täiesti. Küsib, kas Kitti lisada ja. Ja osa projektist. Loomulikult.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, et ee, seda klotsi Oleks võimalik ka voes kasutada.
Õpetaja: Tuleb kirjutada. Nüüd on voe spetsiifiline koodilõik Eksport, default
Õpetaja: ja loogilised Sulud. Algavad Ja enter. Ma ei. Tea Kas tal auto compliiti lubab. Ei, luba. Siin on ikkagi vaja vajutada.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see asi. Teeb ta põhimõtteliselt teistele komponentidele imporditavaks. Kui see siin on, Eksport siis mujal saab olla import. Näete impordil.
Õpetaja: Alert Erroris on ka samamoodi
Õpetaja: eksport. Default Kõik voekomponendid on niimoodi algavad. Nii Siia sisse saab teha nüüd nimelise meetodi. Ja mina pakun, et ee. Minule meeldib seda teha. Hästi, tehniliselt
Õpetaja: minul meeldib vaadata seda piiblit ja panna lihtsalt siia Kanda enda ette Sõna send, Get
Õpetaja: login. Ja see on sõnum, mis läheb teele Request
Õpetaja: Urli pealt. Lihtsalt võtan näiteks, et kui ma võtaks Mingi muu asja võtan. Näiteks selle.
Õpetaja: See oleks Atm Locations Request. Saate mõttest aru. Minul meeldib Niukene nimetamiskonventsioon Nende välja on mõeldud. Selles mõttes Mul meeldib. See on hästi tehniline, sest täpselt seda ta teeb.
Õpetaja: Seda me kutsume kuskilt välja. Me Ei, taha lihtsalt loo kinni panna.
Õpetaja: No võib panna ka. Võib panna niimoodi äri loogiliselt lühemalt, aga minul meeldib tehniliselt, sest et siis ma ei pea siia sisse vaatama ja ma saan juba enamvähem aru. Vaata, et missugust sõnumit saadetakse.
Õpetaja: Kui ta ütleb Zend Post Atm Locations, siis ma tean, et, noh, kui ma näeksin Praegult Seda siis ma teaksin juba peast, et see on sellega seotud, ilma et ma sinna sisse vaatan. Point on see, et me hakkame seda väljakutsumist nägema siin,
Õpetaja: et siis mulle meeldib, et see on Niuke tehniline. No meie siis teeme ka niimoodi. Nagu ma ütlesin, teeme tehniliselt Panen seda siia kõrvale, et mul oleks seda võimalik vaadata. Teen selle lahti
Õpetaja: No te saate minu ekraanilt vaadata. Mina teeks niimoodi meetod. Nimi on Zend Get Login Request.
Õpetaja: Sulud lõppu.
Õpetaja: Mul läks keyboard paigast ära. Panen ta tagasi. English United States.
Õpetaja: Nii, paned surud ära. Juba nüüd teeb selle koodiploki ja koma ka. Võibolla natuke tehakse Spacing Ut niimoodi, et see meetod niimoodi. Paistaks silma.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd hakkame tegema täpselt seda sama asja.
Õpetaja: No mis oli see tehnoloogia, millega me sõnumeid saadame, ei ole sisse ehitatud, mis on igas Browser is kättesaadav ja kohe ka Siit
Õpetaja: aktsias Parame aktsias.
Õpetaja: Noh, siia võiks teha uue template. Ma võibolla mingi hetk. Teen nüüd punktiga. Kutsume siis selle aktsiase muutuja ja objekti abil välja meetodi.
Õpetaja: Tema ootab sisse Mitu parameetrit?
Õpetaja: No mis oli see trikk, mille abil saab alati Control Bga. Ta näitab, aga mitu parameetrit ootab sisse.
Õpetaja: Koma Järgi saab alati selgeks teha kaks vabatahtlik ja meil antud juhul läheb vaja mõlemad sellepärast, et selles konfig osas me saame Ära ka määrata parameetreid, headereid, Igast muid asju just vaatasime ka, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga kõigepealt on meil siis See Worlel on ju
Õpetaja: Nüüd me Teame, et meil on siis see api. Oota ka kriips api. Kõigepealt, et ta saaks aru, et, Ee, asi on. Nagu Pärast teemegi Backendi ka niimoodi. Et ongi. Api on tegelikult väga normaalne. Ja paneme login.
Õpetaja: See pool on paigas
Õpetaja: nüüd komaga ja tuleb edasi. Nüüd, kui te Näete niukseid suuri tähti, Siis see viitab mingisugusele klassile ja siis reeglina tegemist. On nüüd objekt. Tüüp on objekt Ta valesti ringi ju
Õpetaja: on Ju ta on selle klassi objekt Objekt. Niiöelda objekti loomine siin samas koodis Niimoodi literaalina on lihtsalt
Õpetaja: need ee, loogilised sulud. See loob objekti.
Õpetaja: Näete siia sisse. Ta juba pakub igasuguseid. Ee, neid igasuguseid. Ee, neid parameetreid
Õpetaja: Või Propse. Pigem või omadusi või kuidas iganes mõtlete, Headers Näiteks Just kasutasime neid mõlemat, onju?
Õpetaja: No, me keskendume sellele Paramsile, sest et meie piibel ütleb, et parameetrid on olemas. Kui siin ei, ole, siis seda Ei, näita. Vaata,
Õpetaja: mõni teenus. Meile pole params Ee, lükata. Võibolla uuele reale. Ta pani siia niimoodi. Otsa.
Õpetaja: Mis? See viitab nii kooloniga. Paneme, siis on ju. Ja siis, me. Kui on mitu asja, saab olla, siis seda skoopi saab määrata
Õpetaja: Kuidas muidu mingi tuhat asja siin? Kuidas ma saan Nad Paneme ühele reale. Ei, pane komad, skoop.
Õpetaja: Loogilised sulud.
Õpetaja: Lööme jälle alla. Vaata, Enter, Vaata, nüüd ta hakkab. No kogemata. Ta valis selle valiku,
Õpetaja: et ma tahan lõpuks koos niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Mis ma nüüd Kirjutan? Ideaalis. Copy Based in.
Õpetaja: Ma tahan öelda, et kokkuvõttes ma Tahan, et Urlides tuleb nagu siia username
Õpetaja: sõber. Kirjuta kusername Mingi väärtus ja siis tuleb mingi väärtus. Need ongi. Need on põhimõtteliselt need on Urli. Niiöelda parameetreid, aga mitte. Mis ma siia kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Kas me peame seda vist kopeerima? Seda ei pea midagi või need vä? No Jah, Ei, Ei, ei, ei,
Õpetaja: ei, see on respons. Me räägime sõnumi saatmisest. Vaadake, see osa siin on Request.
Õpetaja: Sõnumi saatmine ja ainult seda osa me siia teemegi Sõnumi saatmine.
Õpetaja: Vot väga hea, et meil on siin Niukene. Ee, me tahame, et läheb username sinna Urli.
Õpetaja: Esialgu paneme lihtsalt siia tühjast ringi. Vaata, et saaks lihtsalt koodi teha. Ja teine on
Õpetaja: võibolla see koma siit ära kustutada.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd on niimoodi, et, Ee, Küsimus on see, et. Aga kust tulevad need väärtused?
Õpetaja: Vaadake, nüüd on see jälle see klassikaline asi.
Õpetaja: See meetod ei tea oma välisest elust ööd ega mütsi. Sellest. Me tahamegi teda kasutada korduvalt nii, nagu meie tahame. Kus iganes Ta ei tohi kunagi olla seotud nagu selles mõttes, Näiteks mingi muu asjaga ta ei olegi. Ta on täiesti eraldiseisev koodilõik.
Õpetaja: Nüüd meil on vaja username. I. Meil on vaja, mis dünaamiliselt tulevad sisse
Õpetaja: Nüüd, Kuidas ma pean seda meetodit muutma, et siia oleks võimalik mingisugust infot panna, mis tuleb väljapoolt.
Õpetaja: Noh, Ei, vaata, ma just räägin. Vaata, see asi ei tea ühestki muust asjast mitte midagi. Niimoodi ongi programmeerimine. Me ei taha neid siduda omavahel. Ma tahan Login Views seda kasutada. See on Fine,
Õpetaja: aga see meetod ei ole seotud Mitte ühegi asjaga, mis sa oled.
Õpetaja: Ei, kas sa näed siin Kuskil tatablokki pole Selles see konksu ongi, et need andmed on meil tõesti
Õpetaja: siin. Need andmed on meil. Näed siin Views neid väärtusi Soovime kasutada, aga niimoodi, et
Õpetaja: Ta ei tea midagi sellest. Login View Failist.
Õpetaja: Noh, kopeerime natukene.
Õpetaja: Ei Saa kopeerida datablokki siia.
Õpetaja: Sisendit on vaja. Mis see sisend on meetodis.
Õpetaja: Kuidas me kutsume neid sisendeid?
Õpetaja: Sa tahad käivitada mingit tegevust? Ta ei tea oma välisest elust ööd ega mütsi. Kõik info, mida sa tahad talle anda? Sa pead talle kaasa andma. Meie peame siin lihtsalt looma võimekuse, et on midagi kaasa anda. Kuidas me seda teeme?
Õpetaja: No Mõelge, Come on. Rääkisite mulle meetoditest asjadest. Ja nagu praegult, on nagu vaikus. Nagu Kas te tegite selle?
Õpetaja: No ma kutsume selle meetodi välja Varem või hiljem, Aga praegu ei ole erilist point I kutsuda. Sellepärast, et siia pead tulema. Mingid väärtused ühist ringi ei saa jääda. Ju
Õpetaja: Me peame muutma midagi oma selles
Õpetaja: struktuuris siin, et oleks selline võimekus, et oleks võimalik seda meetodit välja kutsuda ja oleks võimalik siis sinna ka midagi kaasa anda. See asi ei tea oma elust mitte midagi. Ja nii ta peabki olema. Aga kui sa soovid mingeid andmeid siia meetodisse, siis kuidas seda saab? Teha? Jumal, Jumal,
Õpetaja: mida?
Õpetaja: Kuhu Ma kirjutan? String Sööma raskusi taha.
Õpetaja: Password I taha. Kirjutan String siia, sisse,
Õpetaja: Palun Väga Kõigil on mistahes, kes tahab. Logib sisse. Kasutame seda meetodit ja tema parool on string.
Õpetaja: Mis?
Õpetaja: Aga dispunkte ei ole? Vaata, sest siin Ei ole mingit datablokki. Siin ei ole mingeid muutujaid. Vot. Noh, nüüd ma rohkem vihjeid ei anna.
Õpetaja: Pildikas Sildikest on vaja, kuhu
Õpetaja: kuhu on vaja sildikest vaja. See meetod ei tea oma välisest elust ööd ega mütsi.
Õpetaja: Kui ma teen meetodi alert, vaata, siis sinna jääb ka mingi Sisend kaasa. Tal peab olema see võimekus.
Õpetaja: No kuidas, ee, ei ole veel? Keegi peaks tegelikult juba teadma. Noh,
Õpetaja: vot mis asi? See, mis asi. See on seal sees, seal sulgude sees.
Õpetaja: Mis asjad need on?
Õpetaja: No Ei, ole atribuudid. Ei, atribuutideks. Meid ei kutsu parameetreid, nii okei, Aitab sellest siia jamast. Ma võtan korra siis mingi projekti lahti.
Õpetaja: Kus ma saan Aa korra teha?
Õpetaja: Jaavad, me hakkame pihta. Nullist tuleb välja, ei ole, Tegelikult teeme siin. Aa ütleme. Aa, ütleme talle nii.
Õpetaja: Kirjutame siis. Ee, mis? Me tahame Õppe loo õppematerjal oli. On ju
Õpetaja: loo Uus õppematerjal. Ma panen Tab I. Ma panen kohe sisendi Ee, selgita mulle näidetega.
Õpetaja: Oota lahti
Õpetaja: nii java kui ka ja va script i
Õpetaja: Meetodi struktuur
Õpetaja: ja üles ehitus.
Õpetaja: Selgita iga osa juurde, miks neid on vaja?
Õpetaja: Las teeb? Ära. Seni kaua. Lähme teeme selle ära siia, Kui Me tahame kuskilt öelda. Login Service punkt.
Õpetaja: Me tahame käivitada seda nimelist koodilõiku. Kui meil on vaja mingit infot selleks tegevuseks,
Õpetaja: siis tuleb luua Võimekus siia on vaja luua parameetrid nimelised sildikesed.
Õpetaja: No mis võiksid olla? Need nimelised sildikesed. Et täita ära neid asju siin, mis võiks olla esimese sildikese nimi. Username.
Õpetaja: Nii, kas nüüd vastab tõele? Meil on olemas niuke meetod, mida on võimalik käivitada
Õpetaja: ja siia on võimalik kaasa anda Infot, mis sidu seotakse, siis selle käivitamisega seotakse nende muutuja nende sildikestega. Muute nimedega. On nii.
Õpetaja: No küsin, mis me siin tahame siis teha.
Õpetaja: Me tahame öelda, et param username. Ma toon selle kasti. Näed, see on see. Username on vasak pool,
Õpetaja: aga see on väärtus on parem pool. Noh, siin koodis, kus me tahame öelda, et kust tuleb väärtus. Me ei taha öelda, et. Aa,
Õpetaja: siis, kui ma, mis ma siis Kirjutan siia täpselt. User Name.
Õpetaja: Kas see on siin valge?
Õpetaja: Kas see on valge? See? Ja see on see üks ja sama sildikene.
Õpetaja: See Siin on lillas on. See on nagu see osa siin.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd Password Iga täppi pead samamoodi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd saab seda meetodit käivitada niimoodi, et Sa saad käivitamishetkel Visata. Aa, siia sisse. Näed, Teeme niimoodi. Siia.
Õpetaja: Aa, vee,
Õpetaja: w, w, w, w, w, w, w, w, W, W, w, W, W, w, w, W, W, W, W, w.
Õpetaja: See A tuleb siia. See Www tuleb siia. Does It makes sense.
Õpetaja: Nii, vaatame vahepeal, Mis on, ee? Nüüd läheme seda tähtsat asja lugema. Mis meil kokku Kirjutati? Siin Unversion Files
Õpetaja: F Neli. Vaatame, selle loeme läbi.
Õpetaja: Mis? Mis on meetod meetod nimega Koodiblokk. Mis teeb mingit konkreetset tööd. Sa kirjutad koodi ühe Korra annad sellele nime ja sa saad seda hiljem uuesti Ja uuesti kasutada. Päris elu. Analoogiast Meetod on nagu retsept. Retseptil on nimi Koogi Küpsetamine sisendid. On koostisosad ja tulemus. On valmis kook
Õpetaja: Sa ei kirjuta retsepti iga kord uuesti. Kasutad sama retsepti. Ikka ja jälle
Õpetaja: probleem ilma meetodita Koodirida. Üks koodirida, kaks koodi rida, kolm sama kood uuesti rida. Üks sama uuesti, Sama uuesti meetod. Arvuta summa. Kasuta Aruta summa. Kasuta Aruta summa. Kasuta Haruta summa. Pikk, ja korduv, lühike ja Selge
Õpetaja: küsimusi eesmärk, onju? Ja struktuur
Õpetaja: java range tüübikontrolliga keel. Pead alati täpselt ütlema, mis tüüpi on. Sisendid ja väljundid. Süntaks. Nähtavus tagastatav tüüp Nimi, Parameetreid, parameetrid,
Õpetaja: meetodi, Sisu return. Väärtus Vajalik kui tagastustüüpe ei ole. Void näide liida Arvud, A ja B.
Õpetaja: See meetod on välja. Kutsutav Igast failist
Õpetaja: igast failist on võimalik seda välja kutsuda. Objekti abil
Õpetaja: tagastab Ta peab, kui siin on öeldud. Oi, te. Kui siin on int öeldud, siis peab olema retöörlause, kus päriselt on mingi number, mis tagastatakse liida. Arvud. Meetod, mida saab välja kutsuda selle sama nime abil
Õpetaja: sildikesed Int A ja Int B,
Õpetaja: mina. Noh, kohe Vaatan seda ka. Tulemus Koodi koodi osa lootakse. Tulemus, kokku tulemus, tulemus, tulemus,
Õpetaja: Kõik asjad lahti Seletatud Public nähtavus. Kes tohib seda meetodit Kasutada Me räägime valdavalt ja Private. Ainult me muid asju siin ei ei puuduta.
Õpetaja: Ja vahe ongi Väga lihtne, Private It On võimalik ainult selle sama koodi faili sees. Mäletate Helper meetodit? Kohvimasin. Aa, Getwater
Õpetaja: Incore faili. Sees. Public Kutsu, kust tahad? Nii? Vaatame. Tagastustüüp. Mis tüüpi väärtus tuleb välja nimi. Mida meetod teeb Camel Case? Parameetrid, Sisendid koos tüüpidega. Palun. Väga Nähtavus Modifier kutsutakse seda asja.
Õpetaja: Igaüks võib kasutada teistest klassidest ja pakettidest. Private, Ainult see sama klass
Õpetaja: tagastustüüp nagu nendest ei hakka rääkima.
Õpetaja: Miks vaja jaava peab kompileerimisel teadma. Mis tüüpi väärtust oodata? Kui ütled, hint ei saa tagastada. Tere, bla, bla, bla,
Õpetaja: Aa, nimi. Miks vaja Hea nimi Ütleb kohe, Mida meetod teeb? Parameetrid. Miks vaja parameetrid on meetodi koostisosad. Annad meetodile andmed millega ta töötab?
Õpetaja: Andmed, kaks täisarvu String Nimi pole ühtegi sisendit Return miks vaja? Kui meetod arutab midagi välja, peab tulemusega tagastama. Ta ei pea arutama. Ta võib kuskilt andmeid tuua kokku panna. Mida Iganes, Objektid,
Õpetaja: tulemus. See koodilõik ei tea elust ööd ega mütsi. See asi siin tulemus.
Õpetaja: See üks kõva töö, mis siin tehakse ära,
Õpetaja: See läheb lihtsalt kaduma musta auku, kui see kood jõuab omaga lõpuni.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui sa kutsud välja meetodi, mis midagi tagastab ja sa soovid selle infoga Mida käest teha, siis Sa
Õpetaja: muutujasse?
Õpetaja: Kas lõpus ka päriselt on vaja? Selgub ma ka vähemalt alguses teen
Õpetaja: saadab väärtuse tagasi kutsujale, palun väga Täielik näide selgitusega. No nüüd, ülejäänud võite vaadata. Ära Nüüd Jaoskripp on natukene. Lihtsam. Function liida Arvut siin Ei, ole tüüpe ei ole nimed, Ikka on
Õpetaja: märksõna. See on funktsioon nimi, Parameetrid, nimed ilma tüüpideta.
Õpetaja: Bla, bla, bla, blabla. Aerofunktion räägib. Ee, noh, ma ei hakka sellest rääkima. Saate seda vaadata.
Õpetaja: Ma loodan, et see natukene tegi seda asja selgemaks. Ma tegelt veits lootsin, et keegi oleks nagu vähe kiiremini ära pakkunud.
Õpetaja: Kui sa soovid mingisugust see meetodit ja oma välisest elust öelda, mütsi Thats the whole idea korduvkasutus.
Õpetaja: Me ei kirjuta seda kui väärtused on sees, siis. Ee. Siis ta võib nimeline meetod olla. Siis ta midagi, nagu teeb Fine. Aga siis sa midagi muud sellega Ei, saa mingit Variatsiooni sellele ei teki
Õpetaja: nii.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see see osa, mis siin muidugi oli, Return.
Õpetaja: Miks vaja ret? Ee, return. Miks vaja kui meetod arutab midagi välja, peab ta tulemus tagasi andma ilma returnita. Kaoks Tulemus,
Õpetaja: nii. Meil on see olukord praegult siin. Me kutsume välja meetodid, mis tagastab tegelikult promise objekti.
Õpetaja: Tema kutsub selle välja. See kood jookseb läbi must auk Kadunud.
Õpetaja: Meie mõte on see, et kui mina kutsun selle meetodi välja Ja see asi tagastab nagu selle objekti, et ühel hetkel tuleb kõne sisse ja saad oma objekti kätte, et kas on ka staatuse Kõige muuga on ju siis, kui siin return ees pole,
Õpetaja: siis ei ole sellega midagi teha. Sellepärast, et see asi
Õpetaja: jõuab siia lõppu, sureb ära. Nüüd on selline meetod, mis kutsub välja meetodi, mis midagi tagastab.
Õpetaja: Noh, võiksime panna ka nagu siia teenukorra muutuja. Panen.
Õpetaja: Mm,
Õpetaja: ee.
Õpetaja: Promise.
Õpetaja: Näete, ta tagastab promiss objekti.
Õpetaja: Vaata, sina kutsud välja aktsiase kett meetodi. Tema annab sulle promisseobjekti, Mis on Lubadus, et ühel hetkel tuleb vastus
Õpetaja: Kohe ei ole anda
Õpetaja: asünkroonne. Mina saadan sõnumi. Hetkel annan sulle palun minu. Anna sulle lubaduse. See on nagu contract. See on leping.
Õpetaja: Ma Annan sulle mingil hetkel vastuse. Kui ka vastus lõpuks ei tule, siis tuleb mingi timeout Vastus, mis on sisse ehitatud.
Õpetaja: No saadad sõnumi, mitte kunagi Midagi ei tule, aga jäägi ootama. Nagu leht, laev ja laeb ja laev ja midagi Ei, juhtu. Vaata aga põhimõtteliselt on niimoodi, et Sõnum läheb teele, antakse üle. Proviso juures on kuulaja kuulaja. Kuulaja käivitab ka Sten,
Õpetaja: Okei, ühe nendest
Õpetaja: siis kui vastus tuleb, kui vastus ei Tule, Siis ta käivitub lihtsalt selle tenni ja ütleb, et midagi oleks valesti ja ja nii edasi,
Õpetaja: nii et saate aru. Vaata praegult põhimõtteliselt Ta tagastab objekti ja see elaks lihtsalt siin selles promissis.
Õpetaja: Aga see promiss lihtsalt sureb. Ära.
Õpetaja: See sureb ära. See Vastus sureb ära kui Return I pole. Kui ma paneks siia siia. Return,
Õpetaja: Return ja promiss siis ta ei sureks ära.
Õpetaja: Aga meil ei ole mõtet seda muutujat siin teha. Kui me saame kohe olla lihtsalt siia algusesse return,
Õpetaja: siis ei ole vaja.
Õpetaja: Kood tuleb lühem Vot niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on meil olemas See asi, mida saab käivitada, Anna ainult sisse informatsioon. Tema saadab sõnumi ja annab sulle vastuse kui vaja, ja Denne oskavad sellega edasi toimetada,
Õpetaja: Kui me nüüd läheme Control alt.
Õpetaja: Kui me nüüd läheme, selle aktsiase, võib siit ära kustutada või? Vaadake, Control Alth. O
Õpetaja: tsau. Baka Import kadus ära. Miks ta on hall? Ei, tule meil siia. Seda aktsiast. Meil pole aktsiasid vaja. Aktsias on meil siin ju
Õpetaja: Ee controlelt Enne Oli see, et minna Control Shift. Enne oli see, et otsida faile.
Õpetaja: Ee, panin suured tähed. Lv log in View. Ja see siin oli Lihtsalt Control alt. O i love o ilo
Õpetaja: Las olla. Nii, lähme edasi. Nii Nüüd Meie oleme selles If lauses. Siin
Õpetaja: Me oleme siin Selles If lauses
Õpetaja: ku resetti login. Ee, Resetti message. Kui kõik väljad on täidetud. Eesmärk on nüüd siis käivitada, see et tahaks sisse logida,
Õpetaja: Nüüd Meie viitame sellele failile. See on natuke staatiline meetod. Noh, ta ongi. Kui te ütlete suure tähega Ls
Õpetaja: log in service
Õpetaja: ülesse tuli Import Siia tuli import. Vaadake, Näed, Services on. Viitab meie failile. Näed, Services paketis. On need failid
Õpetaja: Väga tore.
Õpetaja: Nii login. Service punkt
Õpetaja: mis meetodit tahame kutsuda. Nüüd me vaatame. Näed, on meetod. M. Meetod ootab sisse. Username ja
Õpetaja: returni asja ei oska siin väga hästi näidata. Aga Tegelikult return Id.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on see, et Control B Ootab sisse Username I. Mis ma siia kirjutan? Nüüd
Õpetaja: me oleme. Nüüd vaatan. Ma panen Kõik Jälle ülejäänud asjad kinni.
Õpetaja: Me oleme praegu siin. Login failis. Meie mängumaa On see fail?
Õpetaja: Noh, mis ma tahan anda? Minu eesmärk on ju anda Ikkagi?
Õpetaja: Jah, minu eesmärk on anda ju neid asju, mis on siin kastides. Need on meil kenasti seotud toetajaga User Name Password on?
Õpetaja: Noh, siis mina. Lihtsalt Nüüd annan selle edasi, et hei käivitise meetod. Ee, this.
Õpetaja: Username
Õpetaja: oma Võin vahepeal vaadata kontori Bga. Ka. Kas Ikka oleks õiges järjekorras Viga tekiks ju kohe, kui ma paneksin siia,
Õpetaja: On ju, et nagu peab jälgima seda asja Username This Password.
Õpetaja: Kohe Teeme väikse peale. Seda siis, kui oleme teinud Nii, Praegusel hetkel ta tegelikult tagastab. Tagastab promis objekti. Millega siis see aktsias oskab toimetada, on ju nüüd praegult keegi temaga nagu muutuasja ei pane. Vaata, et keegi temaga edasi ei toimeta. Aga nüüd on võimalik meil panna. Vaata, et niimoodi tšeenimiseks,
Õpetaja: et siia otsa saab panna kohe, et. Ee, et kui tuleb vastus, siis on Niukene meetod nagu.
Õpetaja: Ja ühtlasi paneme kohe ka, Vaata, et on olemas, Catch.
Õpetaja: Paneme ühe veel, millest ei rääkinud. Aga seekord räägime Finali kolm blokki
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd me kirjutame need loomulikult eraldi Reale. Sina saada sõnum
Õpetaja: niimoodi punktide juures. Selles mõttes. Aga tema lõppkokkuvõttes paneb kõik selle ühte jorusse. Nagu ütleme, nii, punktide juurest on võimalik turvaline minna uuele reale, et see on üldine tava. Kui sa soovid asju nagu viia uuele reale. Kui see on tehtud, vaata, et niimoodi Meetod, meetod meetod. Siis punkti kohalt lüüakse tavaliselt ta alla.
Õpetaja: Nii Nüüd teeme uuesti. Kui Juhul, kui tuleb
Õpetaja: vastus Nüüd on meil vaja sildikest Võiks ise kirjutada. Pead selle härra funktsiooni valmis siia. Aga Control tühik aitab meile väikse põhja teha. Ette Välju ja siis see noolemärk, mis võrdlusmärgiga. Vaadake, ta ei ole üksik. Ta ei ole niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Nii. Selle välju asemel paneme response.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: ja nüüd nüüd tuleb siis selline osa. Vaata, kus me ei tee. Niimoodi, Et hakkame jälle seda koodi. Seda pikka koodi kirjutama, vaid Me kohe. Mõtleme ära, et me tahame seda Responsi Handl ida. Aga oma meetodis.
Õpetaja: Eraldi. Meetodis
Õpetaja: nimelises meetodis. Me tahaksime, et siin meetodite blokis hakkab olema üks meetod. Siis ma alustan seda sõnaga, This.
Õpetaja: Teate, ta pakub juba meetodeid. Mis siin on. Näete, pakub, onju? Neid meetodeid. Nüüd, mida meie teeme? Me teeme niukest trikki, ma Ei, mäle ma ei mäleta. Kas ta saab hakkama? Jaavas, ta saaks ilusti hakkama. Me kirjutame, et on üks uus. Meetod hakkab olema seda pole isegi olemas. Paneme Handle Manageeri nagu handel.
Õpetaja: Login Response Niukene meetod hakkab olema.
Õpetaja: Ja me ütleme, et sinna meetodisse, kui me kutsume ta välja Peame panema need. Ee, läks keel keel paigast ära. Me Peame panema sulud
Õpetaja: ja Me tahame öelda, et see, kui me käivitame nüüd siin meetodi, siis me anname kogu selle response objekti sinna meetodisse kaasa.
Õpetaja: Sest et see, asi elab ja sureb siin,
Õpetaja: teda ei jätku kauemaks, Kui need sulgeda vahe
Õpetaja: nüüd, tema nagu ütleb. Oi, ei ole. Niukest. Meetodit ei ole.
Õpetaja: See Warning on, Ee, see Warning on kollane
Õpetaja: ja Piirn on ka. Kõrvalkollane. On.
Õpetaja: Kui ta oleks pirni peal, siis tema pakub. Aga kas tahad teha siis niukest? Ee, function it. Nagu niukest meetodit.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, pirn. Olgu, ta punane või kollane. Vahet pole, Alter lihtsalt pakub samu asju, mida läheks hiirega.
Õpetaja: Siis meie ütlemegi, et kuule, aga ei ole niukest meetodit, Aga ole hea,
Õpetaja: Tee siis meile niuke Meetod ütleb väikse põhja ette meile.
Õpetaja: Vaadake nüüd ta tuli. Seekord tuli alla poole ka Mis on veits Normaalsem
Õpetaja: Tegin niukse põhja siia ja, noh, mulle tegi siia reale. Ja siin on sildikene respons. Annab veel võimaluse Muuta seda Muuta nime, kui tahaks
Õpetaja: ja vaik vaikimised ja panna retörnima. Aga hetkel on retöörnima, Nagu mitte midagi. Vaata, pole Ta teeb lihtsalt Malli,
Õpetaja: vaata see siin. Ja see siin on nüüd omavahel. Connected
Õpetaja: Siit kutsutakse välja meetodid. Handal, mis asub siin
Õpetaja: Kui me, vajutame, Okei, lepime Selle nimega lepime, et nüüd on küsimus. Kas ta hakkab midagi tagastama? Ei ta teeb tegevusi. Ta teeb tegevusi. Ta ei salvesta midagi, et Hetkel võime selle ära kustutada, aga ta jätab selle meile ette, et juhul kui me tahame, et ta hakkab midagi tagastama,
Õpetaja: noh, mis meil oli Taskisse. Mida, mis pidi tegema? Nüüd teeme uuesti. No meil. Kui kõik läheb hästi,
Õpetaja: User Id S. Salvestatakse Session Story sisse. Paneme, paneme Local Story sisse võtmega User Id.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on esimene asi On see. Vaata, et see respons responsi Sees. On Data, on nii?
Õpetaja: Nii, Ee, see tuleks kuhugi panna.
Õpetaja: Sama asi me saame. Me tahaks seda. Me tahaksime seda kätte saada Näed, me tahaks.
Õpetaja: Me tahame seda kätte saada ja see see. Midagi tuleb kuhugi panna. Esimene tegevus meil ongi siin
Õpetaja: paneks Selle Siis
Õpetaja: paneksime selle vastuse siia Paneme, selle, Võtame siit Sellest responsest.
Õpetaja: Body osa. See Body osa või data? Seda tahame kätte saada. Siis, siin, mis ma kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Jah, ei, ei, kirjuta. Kirjutan This, Aga punkte ei tule.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et ma tahangi öelda, et anna sellele osalejale. Ma tõmban kokku. Anna sellele mingi sisu sellele muutujale.
Õpetaja: Kui ma Ütlen punkti, siis ma hakkaks juba viitama user Id Le ja nii edasi. Ega ma nüüd ükshaaval ei taha settida? Ma saaks nii ka teha. Vaata, login Response. Ma teen korra pikemalt korra vaatamise kohta, onju? Ütlen username, kus sa saad? Response punkt,
Õpetaja: punkt.
Õpetaja: Pusername Niimoodi saaks. Ükshaaval ka teha, Aga see oleks idiootsus, on ju?
Õpetaja: Kui ma saaksin tegelikult ju selle palju lihtsamalt teha.
Õpetaja: See on nagu see, et üks haaval sätiks selle objekti väärtuseid. Aga ma ei Soovi Nii Soovin, et on lihtsalt loogiline respons.
Õpetaja: Kogu sulged ja karvadega.
Õpetaja: Mis iganes tuleb, mis iganes Siit tuleb. Pane login responsi, sest edaspidi ma saan normaalselt progeda,
Õpetaja: viidates sellele objektile ja seal on ainult need väljad pakkuda, mis seal on
Õpetaja: Ja meil on mudel käes olemas.
Õpetaja: Nüüd missioon oli see loogi. Aa Local Storage is. Ära Aa, niiöelda salvestada user Id ja all name
Õpetaja: User Id ja all. Name Noh, tuletame meelde, mis ma kirjutan. Siia.
Õpetaja: Keegi mäletab, kuhu me tahame salvestada.
Õpetaja: No kui hakkad kirjutama Local Storage See on igalt poolt kättesaadav üle projekti Local Storage. Mis ma nüüd kirjutan? Siia,
Õpetaja: Punkt, Mis ma siia kirjutan? Mis ma valin Nendest meetodit. Kas siit
Õpetaja: set item, mida ta sisse võtab? Set item
Õpetaja: võtja väärtust ringidena tagastab midagi, mitte midagi, sest See on tegevus. Kontroll B, Jälle Oot, oot, mis siia on vaja? Siin on vaja ringi. Esiteks,
Õpetaja: Stringi Stringi. Millest võti? Aa, mis see võti Siin on? Esimene Võti ei Ole user, Id.
Õpetaja: Nüüd peale koma peab, ütleb. Tahan väärtust, kus ma selle saan Ja ma panin ju kogu selle sisu, mis tuli siit Mul ee, internetist koos sulgeda ja karvadega. Loogin responsi.
Õpetaja: Ju ma selle sealt kätte saan, Onju, et selle jaoks see mõte ongi,
Õpetaja: et nüüd ma siin saan öelda. This punkt, Login respons nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Mis
Õpetaja: punkt ja user Id, et see sõnum. See objekt, mis tuli nüüd sealt Datast. See elab seal selles. Tee see üks ära, et aega kokkuvõit. Mis ma nüüd teen?
Õpetaja: Tublike kontroll. D, Ole kuskil Siin Real ära Selecti. Midagi siin real, kuskil kontroll. D.
Õpetaja: Näed, teeme niipidi siit, kui vajutad. Aa, Control. Tühik või lihtsalt juba paganed. Aa, mis siin on?
Õpetaja: Näed, ma võin selle paiga niimoodi ülilihtsalt paika saada. Juba Erriga saan kätte Rolname. Ja nüüd juba copy name olemas tehtud.
Õpetaja: Ee, mina vaatan Ruttu taskist. Mis siis järgmine asi on?
Õpetaja: Aa, sellega tegeleme hiljem.
Õpetaja: Nii, panen to do lihtsalt siia. Hetkel to do menüü, kuvamine,
Õpetaja: menüüs, Ee, Loog, out kuvamine.
Õpetaja: Ee, ja siis.
Õpetaja: Ee to do. Ma panen Navigeeri Atms lehele.
Õpetaja: Tehniline võlg. Hetkel ei tegele sellega nii,
Õpetaja: vähemalt selles Coobis on nüüd tehtud.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Läheme tagasi siia. Vaata, onju, et et see osa on tehtud, on nii?
Õpetaja: Aga mis siis, kui tuleb mingi kaka? No Tegeleme sellega. Kontroll, tühik.
Õpetaja: Samamoodi jälle, et saab siit valida nagu selle põhja. Aga mulle meeldib lihtsalt kirjutada Error Reisoni asemel, error
Õpetaja: ja Samamoodi me kasutame sellist lähenemist, et me kirjutame meetodid, mida pole olemas veel. No viisakus oleks muidugi. Nüüd see siit tõsta. Ära ka vaata, On ju, et kui me paneme selle kokku
Õpetaja: ja paneme selle kokku. Vaata, et et need meetodid, mis selles põhimeetodis kutsutakse? Välja, Mäletate seda Kohvinäidet.
Õpetaja: Ee, need alammeetodid võiksid siia nüüd järgneda samas järjekorras, kui siin sees. Kutsud välja mingid meetodid. Esimene meetod, mis kutsutakse välja, on üldse See on ju
Õpetaja: siis oleks mõistlik vaata. Et, esimesena panna kõik need kinni kõigepealt. Järgneb noh. Kontroll, x Sellel joonel
Õpetaja: kõigepealt. Kontrollitakse et, kas saab üldse hakata siin sisselogimist tegema?
Õpetaja: Tegelikult enne seda tuleb isegi. Need oligi juba õiges kohas.
Õpetaja: Ta Tegelikult oligi õiges reset all Messeges, Kas Kõik väljad on täidetud.
Õpetaja: Nad võiksid niukses järjekorras tulla? Miks sellepärast, et see on Niukene väikene hügieen
Õpetaja: Nüüd siin. Me soovime teha nüüd täpi pealt sama lähenemist, mis me tegime siin. Me tahame teha nimelise koodilõigu, mis handlib seda errorit.
Õpetaja: Siis Mis ma siia kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Mm, ei s Sest et see peab olema siin blokis. Aa, okei,
Õpetaja: no. Tema pakub seda vana meetodi nime. Ma natukene hüppasin. Handen login error
Õpetaja: samamoodi. Ee, Tal peavad olema sulud. Meetodi välja. Kutsumisel peavad olema sulud.
Õpetaja: Ja jällegi. Vaata, see objekt elab ja sureb ainult selles sulgude vahel. Kas saate aru. Ta on kutupiilu.
Õpetaja: See meetod tegelt ei tea oma välisministerist suurt midagi. Noh, siin selles kontekstis me saame need data asjadele igast meetodist ligi, et see on ainukene asi, millele me saame ligi, on ju Aga ülejäänud asi, mis on kuskilt mujalt, tuleb seal tuleb kaasa anda. Me ütleme, et anna see error sinna alla kaasa.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ta vingub jälle. Vaata, et. Oi, oi, oi, Kutsu välja meetodid. Mida pole olemas, Pirn pirn. Altenter. Alati pakub, et. Kuule, kas sa soovid? Teeme siis siukse meetodi. Vaatame, kuhu ta viskab. Selle
Õpetaja: lihtsalt isegi saab. Paneb õigesse kohta järjekord. Ma ei tea, kas ta paneb alati kõige alla. Vaata praegu lihtsalt juhuslikult või mitte. Aga täpselt meile sobivas kohas, on ju
Õpetaja: Võibolla nii palju võib teha. Noh, ütleme Entreid. Aa, midagi ta returnima ei hakka.
Õpetaja: Selle osa võib ära kustutada ja võibolla võib siis teha Nii palju, et, Ee,
Õpetaja: jah, rohkem ei olegi praegu midagi. Mis me Erroriga pidime tegema? Erroriga? Me pidime vaatama juhul, kui staatus on nelisada Kolm ja selle A. Kõigepealt sama asi. Paneme selle vastuse nüüd kuhugi elama. Ka.
Õpetaja: Paneme ta siia elama.
Õpetaja: Mäletate jälle? Meil tuleb vastus.
Õpetaja: Läks halvasti. Me teame, et halvasti Catch Block käivitus sellepärast, et nelisada kolm on.
Õpetaja: Aga me tahame nüüd seda kätte saada. Meid huvitab see, tegelikult Huvitab see ka.
Õpetaja: Noh, me võime veel eraldi teha. Tegelikult me võime niimoodi, et ütleme. Error punkt.
Õpetaja: Ma Ütlen, et seda ei teaks. Vaata, Näete, ta pakub nüüd response. Siin on ju respons. Ta on mitmekihilisem, muud midagi.
Õpetaja: Ja sealt võtaksime näiteks üldse selle staatus staatuse numbrina
Õpetaja: ja paneks selle muutuasse. Ma ei tea, kas ta lubab või mitte. Pirn on. Vaata, kollane pirn. Alter.
Õpetaja: Näete niukest valikut. Introduce Local varjab, võtame selle lihtsalt, et ei oleks pikka teksti. Edaspidi paneme siin status number.
Õpetaja: Saite valida Õnnestus teil saa. Te peate olema kuskil siin rea lõpus Või seal. Vähemalt selle osa peal, et ta saaks aru. Me kirjutasime tegelikult praegult parema poole ennem ja tegime ee, mis ta seda näitab, et status meeldi.
Õpetaja: Aa, ta lihtsalt ütleb, et seda pole veel kasutatud. No jah, Hold Your Horses, onju?
Õpetaja: Nii samamoodi Teeme error,
Õpetaja: aga siin Tasub pika. Siin tuleb teistmoodi teha. Teeme vasaku poole ennem. Me tahame kogu selle responsi Data Bloki
Õpetaja: body. Tahame siia panna. Vaata, see kogu Error responsis on eraldi staatus. See siin on data.
Õpetaja: Selle Me soovime siduda selle responsobjektiga, et edaspidi on minna. Aa, niiöelda meile. Siis ja Selle võib üldse panna konst,
Õpetaja: Sest et tema sisu ei saa enam kunagi muutuma. Vaata onju, et me lihtsalt ühe korra küsime ja paneme
Õpetaja: Nüüd siia kirjutame. This punkt Error respons
Õpetaja: Ütleme. Et. Kuule nüüd, Error I. Seal sees on response ja seal on data.
Õpetaja: Vot nii, nüüd on meil kõik olemas.
Õpetaja: Meil on kõik olemas selleks, et nüüd me saaksime teha seda If lauset,
Õpetaja: et vaadata, et, ee, kuule, kui on Nelisada, kolm ja message on üks. Üks. Siis palun täida ära see error Message, mis trigerdab selle Alerdi meele Visuaalis on arusaadav.
Õpetaja: Vaata, Backiga on nii mõnus tagasi minna.
Õpetaja: Okei, näed? Vot see on õige.
Õpetaja: No ütleme, oota. Ma lisan selle ka siia, kui mitte jälle
Õpetaja: seitseteist, kui Mitte ainult buss. Kõigil on. Oi, kurat, Sa ei jõudnud tikkida.
Õpetaja: Kohe ütlen, millal võib vajutada nuppe
Õpetaja: nii Mm
Õpetaja: juurde.
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: kui käsitsi järgi tulla, Siis saab juba roll. Back Ida on ju?
Õpetaja: No Ee.
Õpetaja: Võib teha käsi püsti, kes praegu tulevad järgi.
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: käsi püsti. Keda veel Peab vaatama
Õpetaja: kedagi. Ei julge kätt tõsta. Kes võib edasi liikuda Liigume.
Õpetaja: Aa. Jõudsime siis siia, et, ee, meil on olemas. Nüüd info meil on status number, mis meil tuli. Meil on olemas kõik kombinatsioonid on asjadest olemas eraldi muutujatele osana siin, et me saame nüüd siis kontrollida Seda osa.
Õpetaja: Kui status C on kolm ja kod on üks üks siis kuvada message vea, teade.
Õpetaja: Noh, hakkame pihta, siis ma kirjutan siia,
Õpetaja: Noh, öelge teie mulle. Ma olen täiesti uus arendaja. If, Mis ma siia kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Noh, julged sisistada Status number, mis me temaga tahame vaadata, Mis me tahame vaadata? Väga mõtlen
Õpetaja: kolm lausa tüübikindel ära. Mis See, mis see tähenda eks? Praegu, et et me paneks
Õpetaja: staatusnambril ta muud väärtust anda.
Õpetaja: Aga see tähendaks, et kui üks neist on String Ee nelisada kolm ja teine on number nelisada. Kolm, siis nad oleks tõesed, Aga me tahame alati teha kõike Kontrolli tüübikindlalt, et ta vaatab, et mõlemad on pooled on võrdsed.
Õpetaja: Mis veel and, and, mis ma siia kirjutan.
Õpetaja: No mis ma kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Kus Kohas on? Praegult mul. Ee, need andmed.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: Ee, this error respons. Siin sees on ju kogu staff A. Mina ei taha kogu staff i võrrelda. Mina tahan vaadata ainult,
Õpetaja: siis, mis ma kirjutan. Ja niimoodi oleme sügavamal objektis ja nüüd
Õpetaja: nii If Lause on tehtud. Teeks talle body ka. Mis on see keyboard shortcut.
Õpetaja: Siis lõp auto compliit ja teeb ee rea lõpu ära.
Õpetaja: Control Shift Enter.
Õpetaja: Näete, teeb selle lõpu meil ära. Lööme ühe entri juurde ja olemegi omadega teel. Nüüd Eesmärk oli siis, see, et peame näitama Message veade, valekasutaja.
Õpetaja: Raul, Jälle peame näitama. Ahah, peame näitama,
Õpetaja: millega on see näitamine. Näed, see näitamine on siis, kui on sisu, siis näidatakse, Kui mitte, siis ei näidata.
Õpetaja: See on seotud selle muutujaga.
Õpetaja: Tema algseis on tühjus. Kui me tuleme siia meetodisse, siis tehakse ette, Tema algseis on Igal juhul tühjus
Õpetaja: garanteeritud. Nüüd me tahame öelda, et saad uue sisu.
Õpetaja: Noh, kes saab uue sisu
Õpetaja: Error Message This Punkt error message
Õpetaja: Kuidas saab uut sisu anda? Programmeerimises
Õpetaja: Võrdusmärgiga, kus me saame selle sisu tahakski? Seal öeldud
Õpetaja: Tahakski sulle, öelda et selle peab saama
Õpetaja: peateade tuleb võtta error sõnumist message väljalt.
Õpetaja: No, kus meil see kogusõnum on?
Õpetaja: See on kogu sõnum.
Õpetaja: Mm,
Õpetaja: no see on kogu aeg selles ühes samas responsis selles objektis, kui me vaatasime koodi me vaatasime, Ka Võõrdub üks üks. Vaatasime
Õpetaja: selles. See mõte ongi. Selle mõte on, see et me ei peaks toimetama niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Näed, kui ma paneksin kogu aeg niimoodi nagu. Mingi. Oota,
Õpetaja: no see oleks vastik. Lihtsalt. Ja ta joonib alla ka, Ta Ei tea, kas seal on midagi või ei ole Alla ei jooni, Aga sa võtad eelse. Saate aru,
Õpetaja: meil Elab kogu see, kogu See osa me iga kord kasutame sama asja, kui me saame mingi vastuse. Me tahame ta kuhugi muutujasse panna. Databloki, et meil oleks mudel, Mis seal sees on?
Õpetaja: Kui Ei, ole, seda osa seal üleval, siis me lihtsalt ei tea. Võime. See tehniliselt töötab kõik väga hästi ka Niimoodi, Pane taskusi ja number üks niikuinii oma. Sisu saab ka internetis, Aga niimoodi me ei teaks, mis siin on. Tahaks ka panna, et on tühist ring.
Õpetaja: See pole väga abistav meile. Me tahame just, et. Oot, oot, anna meile mudel.
Õpetaja: Tegi ta nüüd seda tagasi.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis on see olemas Siin Tahame samamoodi öelda. Rmesse. Sa võtad this punkt error.
Õpetaja: Jah, sest et Kui sa. Paned selle punkti ära, paned kontrollit tühid, siis sa näed, mida ta pakub. Juba.
Õpetaja: See on ikka lihasmälu Veits Lõpuks, et siit tahaks seda message.
Õpetaja: Noh, väga hea, nüüd me Oleme põhimõtteliselt. Ee, A Else tuleb ka.
Õpetaja: Ja see tuleb ka teha, onju? Ma panen selle praegu to do Navigeeri
Õpetaja: Ups, midagi läks valesti
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et me peame mõtlema, et see on meie enda programmeeritud viga.
Õpetaja: Back end is vale kasutajanimi või?
Õpetaja: Aga kui tuleb mistahes muu viga
Õpetaja: mida me ei ole ära programmeerinud, siis kasutaja ei saa lihtsalt jääda sellele lehele teadmatusse.
Õpetaja: Aga meil ei ole midagi nagu väga seal, nagu talle muud öelda, kui et kurat, midagi oleks valesti.
Õpetaja: Aga see oleks halb, kui ta lihtsalt jääks sinna
Õpetaja: muudkui vajutust, seda loogiline nuppu, midagi, ei toimu
Õpetaja: serverist. Ütleme, andmebaas on maas. Mida iganes koodis on mingi viga, Istub muudkui klõbistab oma nuppu ja läheb vihaseks juba ja hakkab meile helistama, onju?
Õpetaja: Ta mingi Ups, midagi läks valesti. Siis on nagu see, et. Okei, midagi läks kohe totaalselt uksi. Võtan klienditeenindusega ühendust, et Mina Ei tea, mis värk on. Aga
Õpetaja: Miks midagi valesti? No siis uuritakse, mis toimub.
Õpetaja: Seda Me veel ei. On vaja ära navigeerida. Handel Login error tehtud.
Õpetaja: Nii finally. Mm,
Õpetaja: muutuja juurde. Siia ülesse.
Õpetaja: Loading spinner. Ee, kirjutame.
Õpetaja: Ee, või paneme. Ee. Disloading.
Õpetaja: Mulle meeldiks natuke rohkem see nagu puulion. Mäletate puhul on hästi tähtis asi, et mis vormis? Ta peab olema.
Õpetaja: Nimi Kuidas
Õpetaja: meetodi nimi peaks olema? Positiivne? Vaata eitav ei tohiks olla. Aga mis on, mis vormis Peaks olema nimi?
Õpetaja: Ah nii, me ei pea olema Tegusana See ei ole see, mis ma otsin,
Õpetaja: Ta on väide statement. Hüüumärk peab see olema is loading,
Õpetaja: mitte Siin See ei ole enam.
Õpetaja: See ei ole enam statement Sellepärast, kui sa Paned selle If I. Vaata, if is it Loading on nagu
Õpetaja: toimub if is loading Siis juba Võibolla kõnetab
Õpetaja: Saate. Aru, Ta peab olema Statement. See on niikuinii Jaava konventsioon.
Õpetaja: No algväärtuse. Ma paneksin sellele koos.
Õpetaja: Ma olen koma.
Õpetaja: Teeme veits funktsionaalsust juurde.
Õpetaja: Ee. Otsime näiteks üles see Ulträpp.
Õpetaja: Spinner,
Õpetaja: oled seda asja näinud?
Õpetaja: Kahjuks, jah.
Õpetaja: Noh, seal on mingi, et.
Õpetaja: No kes tahab oma projekte teha? Pange hoopis ee loading Spinner Nagu
Õpetaja: Css. Ma ütleks näiteks. Pange ja minge kohe niuksele lehele. Nagu Css näiteks.
Õpetaja: Noh saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: On veel uhkemaid,
Õpetaja: on idiootsaid lausa Mingid traktorid sõidavad ja ma ei tea, mida iganes. Nagu päris. Nagu mingid suured veldid. Nagu mingi Ultimate. Aga meie, nagu läheme, läheme seda, teed pidi, et võtame midagi siit.
Õpetaja: Võibolla see mulle meeldib. See.
Õpetaja: Näete, see is loading.
Õpetaja: Ma vaatan korra. Kus see päris see patt on, Siis on nagu ka. Kas see saab muutuda?
Õpetaja: Status? Mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Jah, see tunduks Niukene. Okei, asi ee. Võtame. Tulete ka või võite järgi tulla, või mis iganes ka Tegelikult, mis on, vaja on, on Baton Batonile Tuleb lihtsalt Aa juurde.
Õpetaja: Spänn. See osa nüüd on päriselt see Spinner, See on tekst.
Õpetaja: Loading.
Õpetaja: Võtame selle Buttoni.
Õpetaja: Isegi sobib loading see on. See on see Eesti keelne Värk on see laadin
Õpetaja: iga kord, Kui ma näen sinna. Aa, Kuidagi tundub imelik see asi. Lähme Button I ülesse. Kus on meie Paton? Meie Baton on siin, on nii?
Õpetaja: Paneme selle siia alla.
Õpetaja: Põmm.
Õpetaja: Nüüd lähme korra vaatama, kuidas ta meie lehel välja näeb. Kas ta. Kas teda üldse praegult näitab?
Õpetaja: Näitab, aga ei näita seda teksti. Natuke on vaja aru saada.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma mõtlen korra.
Õpetaja: Ee, Miks seda teksti ei näe alumisest pilti pealt võtma Aa, Bergele.
Õpetaja: Jah, You Learn Something Everyday alumise.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: on onju? Pärast. Ärme hakka muretsema isegi sellepärast, et. Ee, me nüüd teeme, niimoodi et näed Ühte või teist.
Õpetaja: Meil on siin kaks Patonit järjest.
Õpetaja: Siis ma paneks pigem selle siia. Ettepoole ülemisele kirjutaks Vave
Õpetaja: Aa, ma teeks hästi natuke teistpidi.
Õpetaja: Võtame selle veef I korraks siit maha. Ma ei taha ehitust. Teha Ehitust saab teha alati No, problem pannud hüüumärgi ette, aga ma ei tahaks koodis teha ehitust ka, kui saab vähegi. Ma panen järjekorra teistpidi.
Õpetaja: See on loading Button.
Õpetaja: Ja ma lihtsalt vahetasin nende positsioonid ära Nagu, Noh, visuaalselt. Nad näevad seda niimoodi välja.
Õpetaja: Selle loading. Paneme rõvedalt. Laadin, Mis tegelt võiks olla Aen
Õpetaja: Noh, siin. Konkreetselt võib olla ka
Õpetaja: Midagi taolist Saate mõttes ära veel.
Õpetaja: No hästi, natukene. Käib selle spänni puhul, nagu et see tekst on minu maitse jaoks liiga nagu selle elukaga seljas,
Õpetaja: et ma ütleksin. Võibolla siin jälle. Nagu. Vaata, et ma tahan, et see asi lükkab parempoolset teksti eemale. See on nüüd see, Mis see Spin Ib?
Õpetaja: Ma siia Class I juurde paneksin. Marchin end.
Õpetaja: Ja kas kui üks? Ütlen, et hoia nagu hästi väikest vahet arv,
Õpetaja: Kas on spänd? Ta ei oska siis seda hoida nagu vä.
Õpetaja: No siis on nii ei viitsi mina piksel taga ajada. Las see olla Nii login sisse,
Õpetaja: on nii? Ja nüüd me teeme selle tingimuslikuks. Millal on mõistlik seda näidata siis? Kui, east Loading On true Vastab tõele
Õpetaja: Aa, mis on programmiliselt siis mudima Vastavalt siis siia üle. Mis sa teen, V? If.
Õpetaja: Pane lihtsalt East Loading.
Õpetaja: Hetkel peaks näitama ainult loo kinni.
Õpetaja: Ma kujutan ette, et alustame. Login. Aa, nüüd by the way Ka. Need. On siin. Tuleb eelse teha ka.
Õpetaja: Need nad. Peavad need. Elemendid peavad tulema, siis järjestikust niimoodi üksteise riburada pidi. Kui siin on V If, siis siia teeme. V
Õpetaja: Else. See On If Else Põhimõtteliselt Näita seda
Õpetaja: elementi, mille sees see on. Defineeritud eelse. Näita seda Nüüd on üks või teine.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui lihtsalt proovida, ma saan korra selle East Louding u ära muuta. Panna. Lihtsalt true.
Õpetaja: Kujutame ette. Vaata, et loen. Laen sisse. Vaata siis selle järgi. See hakkab olema loomulikult. Tema Väike väärtus hakkab alati olema False, et teda ei näidata.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: kuidas kes?
Õpetaja: Jah, nii nüüd minu küsimus on. Millal peaks selle East loading u panema niiöelda aktiivseks,
Õpetaja: kui sa nupule vajutad, et kui sa vajutad nupule, login. Vaata, meil on siis see reset terror Message hetkel onju
Õpetaja: Ma teeks ka eraldi meetodi. Aa, ma teeksin eraldi meetodid sellepärast, et ma tahan praegult timeout i kasutada. Ee, päriselus. Cloud hakkaks ka jälle. Ee, et nagu, et ära tee nagu mingi ühe rea peale koodi. Aga mina ütlen, et kui tahad teha väga loetavat koodi alga sõbralikult, Siis miks ka mitte Teeme niukse meetodi.
Õpetaja: Start.
Õpetaja: Loading Control Sett Enter Ja võib kohe siia otsa panna ka stop loading,
Õpetaja: et see sama Kood, mis me siia sisse kirjutame, on tegelikult ee, väga lühikene start. Loading tähendab seda, et siis loading u väärtus peab. Olema
Õpetaja: True, on ju nii on.
Õpetaja: No start loading. Vaata, see on see, et nagu hakkame laadima Spinnert. Kas kas start Spinner nagu kuidagi kõnetaks rohkem teid või Mida iganes,
Õpetaja: show, spinner või midagi. Ma ei tea, kuidas te mõtlete. Vaata
Õpetaja: Võibolla mõtleme seda. Vaata, et oleks ka edaspidi sama lähenemine,
Õpetaja: Ma mõtlen nagu seda. Vaata, et see võiks olla nagu geneeriline.
Õpetaja: Ee, et kui me ei lae andmeid, aga hoopis postitame andmeid, See võib olla nagu kes tahtis minna.
Õpetaja: Ja selle asja paneme selle refaktureerime. Is. Loading U refaktureerime ära. Shift F Kuus siit
Õpetaja: Ja selle asemel paneme Hoopis show.
Õpetaja: Spinner, kui tahaks pikalt panna, Spinner. Aga me selles kontekstis juba niikuinii teame. Mis siis Spinner meile tähendab?
Õpetaja: Jose Spinner.
Õpetaja: Kui ta on truu, Siis näitab, kui on False ei näita, sobib,
Õpetaja: Ee, võis olla ka praegu mujalt, sest et ma ei usu, et ta kuskil midagi mujal muutis, saab siit kohe vaadata.
Õpetaja: Jah, ee, see on see koht, mida tegelikult saaks siis vaadata. Aga tegelikult oleks pidanud ise mõtlema Sellele Aa, rohkem on probleeme, kui tahaks mingit niukest asja projektis mingi hetk
Õpetaja: veel faktureerida konkreetses kohas, sest et see raisk läheb võtab igalt poolt ja siis lähevad asjad tuksi. Või ei ole soovitud tulema siis,
Õpetaja: et hetkel kuskil ei olnud viis loodingut niikuinii. Nii, nüüd on mul Siin üleval See Button Show. Spinner. Et siin on need ka Spinner. Spinner. Spinner. Nii et ta kõnetab küll, onju
Õpetaja: ja all on ka selles mõttes alla. Ma ei jõudnud veel midagi teha. Selle meetodi me siis muudame. Ära Seda ei pea reflektoreerima kuskil pole kasutatud startspinner
Õpetaja: ja Stop, Spinner on lihtne.
Õpetaja: Mina. Ma. Mulle meeldiks meeldiks niimoodi, sest mulle meeldib ikkagi lugeda rohkem Teksti ja koodi tähendab teksti kui inglise keelt, Mitte teksti, kui koodi.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et lahendus sulle tuleb. Selline Kui ma tahan, et Spinner hakkaks käima, siis ma lihtsalt ütlen, Show Spinner
Õpetaja: võrdub No prou.
Õpetaja: Noh, ja stopi. Lihtsalt tuleb sees pools.
Õpetaja: Noh, ee, võib ka mõelda. Võibolla kui kasutasime sõna, ütleme see ongi normaalne protsess mõtlemine, et kui meil tegelikult on seal selle muuta nimi showspinner, siis võibolla saakski kirjutada, et see on hoopis showspinner. Ja see on
Õpetaja: Heid Spinner,
Õpetaja: Aa, nüüd natukene läks halvasti. Meetodi nimi kattub selle muutuja nimega.
Õpetaja: See ei taha niimoodi. Ee,
Õpetaja: siis Control Setiga võtaks Tagasi kui on stop Ja start. Ma ei viitsi rohkem öelda. Saaks muuta asju, teha, mida iganes. Ei lisa väärtust.
Õpetaja: No, põhiline asi on see, Vaata, et niipea Kui kasutaja vajutab nuppu, siis temale visuaalselt. Tahaks anda tagasisidet, et midagi toimub. On nii
Õpetaja: siis siin, mis? Ma kutsun välja
Õpetaja: ja pissi abil Startspinner.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Kuidas töötab Van Niimoodi Tren ja Catch on Teineteist välistavad.
Õpetaja: Kui on hea sõnum käivitub see kui on halb sõnum, käivitub see, Mis Te arvate, mis Finali teeb?
Õpetaja: Kuidas viis lihtsalt käivitab Recardless, kumb neis käivitub täiesti lõpus.
Õpetaja: Sa saad siin teha mingisugust dekonstruktsiooni või mida iganes, et sul on mingi setup, Tahad midagi taastada või Mis iganes finali see järjekord on nii käivitub see
Õpetaja: või see, aga see käivitub Nii või naa
Õpetaja: meil eelkõige. Tegelikult huvitab see muidugi Catch I puhul. Sellepärast, et oleme Kui trenn käivitub siis kasutaja, saadetakse minema niikuinii,
Õpetaja: ehk Siis kui isegi see Spinner seal mingi sekundi või kaks nii öelda spinnib siis järgmine. Kui kõik läheb hästi, siis viiakse kasutaja niikuinii minema, et tehniliselt võttes siit ei oleks vaja kasutada. Aga Catch i puhul küll.
Õpetaja: Saadad sõnumi Ot Otsin otsin, otsin vale kasutaja nimi ja siis Vaata, on ju. Saate mõttest aru,
Õpetaja: et see, et see nagu selles mõttes oleks nagu. Niimoodi Aga selles mõttes. Ee, see finali, isegi kui Ta taustal hakkab käivituma, siis tegelikult selleks hetkeks on kogu see vaade vaateinfo juba ära kustutatud. Kui me oleme uuel lehel, juba
Õpetaja: aga Fineli on väga okei garanteerida Et Recardness. See Selle Finali mõte on tegevused, mis käivituvad lõpus nii või naa peale seda
Õpetaja: pihta, kui sa oled Nagu
Õpetaja: Vaata see, see finali. Vaata uuele lehele. Me siis ei lähe, kui saame. Vea on Mul õigus.
Õpetaja: On ju, et selles mõttes see Finali mõte on nagu see, et need on. Ära unusta ära, et need kaks blokki on teineteist välistavad. Mõlemad ei saa käivitada,
Õpetaja: aga see ongi mõeldud programmiliselt see finali on see, et mingi järeltegevus kumb neis käivitub?
Õpetaja: Sest et siin praegu me läheme mujale lehele, aga kogu aeg Nii ei ole ju. Ma ei tea, Lisa. Mingisugune uus asukoht
Õpetaja: ee süsteemi. Kui lisatakse midagi hästi, siis kuva mul uuesti. Tabeliandmeid tuuakse uuesti Backendist ära finalis, Saad siis veel toimetada midagi. Mis iganes, kui tuleb viga. Finali, on Finally Finally on lihtsalt see If else
Õpetaja: ee. Või Noh, ma ei oska tegelt päris see, see, et vahet pole, kumb nendes blokkides käivitub, siis Mis iganes tegevuses käivitatakse finalist, nad käivituvad ka Ja Mei meil klassikaliselt See ongi Niukene, mis meil on vaja teha. Spinner oleks vaja kinni panna. Ju
Õpetaja: tuli viga. Kes ikka näitab, et Login sisse või? Ei ole vist vaja enam hiljem ka kinni.
Õpetaja: Mis asi meetodi sees veel kirjutada? Et kui panna seda, kuhu siia lõppu Vä, Jah, saaks nii ka saaks.
Õpetaja: Ja saaks küll
Õpetaja: absoluutselt. Ja tegelikult isegi olekski parem koht sellepärast, et vaata, kui kasutaja vajutab, täida kõik väljad, siis ärme unusta ära. Spinner on alustatud, on ju
Õpetaja: Ma korra? Vaatan ka. Siin on tegelikult peaks panema need sulud ka juurde,
Õpetaja: et Vaata, Spinner hakkab käima. Mängime läbi. Spinner hakkab käima. Kõik väljad ei ole täidetud. Mis ta siis teeb? Täida kõik väljad. Spinner ikka käib ja loogil nuppu enam vajutada ei saa, sest on peidetud. Tegelikult siin kontekstis. Isegi seda finali. Sa võid dubleerida seda ka enda kui tahad
Õpetaja: Saatu mõttes aru,
Õpetaja: Stoppi
Õpetaja: ma. Ma tegelt tahtsin lihtsalt rääkida, et teil on lihtsalt niisugune võimalus, et teil on mingisugune sõnumi saatmine ja mingisugused Tegevused. Mis on Happy Bad. Ja siis teil on veel kolmas blokk olemas. Mis saab? Lihtsalt käivitub aga lõpus peale neid teisi järjekord on alati nii.
Õpetaja: Sõnum läheb teele. Ootame, ootame promiseid. Tuli õnnelik vastus. Käivitatakse see ja käivitatakse Peale seda otsa tuleb halb vastus. Käivitatakse see ja Peale selle tegevust käivitatakse see otsa. Et see võim. See on tööriist,
Õpetaja: aga praegult tõesti. Ee, Kuule, mul on jälle su nimi meelest ära tagumine, Hendrik, et selles mõttes Hendrik enamvähem tegelikult viitas sellele, et sama hästi saab siia panna mingi järeltegevuse ja tegelikult ongi õige, sest ma Unustasin selle asja ära, et meil on ka selline olukord.
Õpetaja: Muidu on ju nagu start Spinner. Kõik läheb peitu. Spinnerit Näed, täida kõik välja, et. No teeme nagu praegu. Selle Ära vaata Palun väga.
Õpetaja: Täida kõik välja, et sellel nupul mingit funktsionaalsust Pole ju
Õpetaja: ilus vaadata, Aga nüüd on nagu Refresh. Vaata, okei?
Õpetaja: Aga noh, see ei ole ju see,
Õpetaja: et spin igasuguste errorite ja asjadega Ma ei mäleta, miks see resetterror on Ka see, et me peame manageerima seda, et kuidas inimesed vajutavad. Mis seisu nad jäävad, et me alustame alati puhtalt led ja me Lõpetame alati puhtalt led.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis Siia Lõppu oleks mõistlik panna see Osa ee.
Õpetaja: See, Osa täida. Kõik väljad siia. Tuleb. Siis kirjutada ves Punkt Stop, Spinner.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi Nüüd on nagu see. Vaata, et täida kõik väljad.
Õpetaja: Noh, visuaalselt me ei näe nagu midagi siin, onju? Vaata, aga Mul on võimalus nüüd ikkagi uuesti siin toimetada.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on natukene nagu simuleerida seda asja ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma ei, tea, kas niimoodi saab, Ma Proovin ka ära.
Õpetaja: Aa, set timeout. Kas ma pean tingimata midagi käivitama? Ma ei mäleta, Ma panen koma ära. Ma panen näiteks seda, et, Ee, kaks sekundit. Tee midagi. Ma mõtleks ma anonüümseks. Võin seda jätta. Kuidagi.
Õpetaja: Ma küsin korra. Lihtsalt. Ee, vaata, see on niimoodi, et tee midagi.
Õpetaja: Aa, ma võin nii ka teha. Ja siis peale kahte sekundit. Need on millisekundid. Käivita mingi tegevus. Ma võin siia panna ka Tegelikult, Ee, ma ei oska niimoodi teha, et ära käivita midagi. Ma ütlen, et ee.
Õpetaja: Siin on niukene asi. Vaata, kui kõik vormid on väljast täidetud. Ma mängin nagu. Vaata, on.
Õpetaja: Ee. Kaks sekundit on siin väike paus.
Õpetaja: Seejärel käivitatakse Stop, spinner.
Õpetaja: Ma natuke simuleerin, seda et andmeid näed, Täidan kõik väljad ära.
Õpetaja: Sõnum läheb teele.
Õpetaja: Viga ei saa, okei?
Õpetaja: Aga ei. Sellepärast, et see asi jõuab kohe lõppema. Korra kommenteerin selle välja, Niimoodi saan seda teha
Õpetaja: ja. Ja. Ja. Ja
Õpetaja: ma korra proovin uuesti. Vaata seda Seda on tüütu. Tüütu on simuleerida, et vastusega läheb aega.
Õpetaja: Oota, ma küsin ikkagi. Vaata, kuidas ma saaks Lihtsalt vaata panna lihtsalt siin väikse pausi. Ma küsin lihtsalt ee
Õpetaja: ee, kuidas ee tekitada Siia Ee, reale.
Õpetaja: Ee, sada siia alla. Ee, väike kahe sekundiline.
Õpetaja: No paneme rohkem neli.
Õpetaja: Ee, sest et ma. Ma Ei, mäleta. Ma ei tea seda. Kuidas? Aa, kuidas saab?
Õpetaja: Ah juba. Ta hakkab siin jamama.
Õpetaja: Ee, promis.
Õpetaja: Okei, kui see koodirida seda aitab teha, siis Ee, nii on,
Õpetaja: Ee, ma võtan selle niikuinii siit ära ja ma võtan enda selle tehtud.
Õpetaja: Noh, okei, Davai, Vaatame, tulen siia. Login sisse. Liiklus võtab aega.
Õpetaja: Kas ma kommenteerisin siit alt välja selle stop spinneri. Jah, okei, nüüd ühe korra veel uuesti.
Õpetaja: Aa, login.
Õpetaja: Going on.
Õpetaja: No üks Refresh veel
Õpetaja: korra on vaja vaadata Back endast, mis toimub nagu, Või noh, ta taustal. Kas sõnum läheb üldse teele? Ma hetkel nagu jääb segaseks, nagu Vaata, et mismoodi Ta käitab.
Õpetaja: Sõnum saadeti ühe korra, nagu töötas. Põhimõtteliselt vä.
Õpetaja: Aa, mis juhtub? Aa, mis juhtub? See on asünkroonne. Kurat, ma Unustan kogu aeg selle ära.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma unustan seda kogu aeg. Ära vaata, et vaata, Kui see sõnum läheb teele,
Õpetaja: meil Ei, oota see osa tähendab see. See kood läheb edasi. Selles mõttes et see kood käivitub, minnakse edasi kohe selle osaga. Sellepärast, et see tegevus on asünkroon. Ülejäänud kood ei hoia meie sõnumi taga
Õpetaja: ma pean lihtsalt selle korra panema. Ee, välja ja Panema. Korra lihtsalt selle ajutiselt korra sinna händimise sisse. Kus see paus on? Vaata, see paus on siin.
Õpetaja: See rida siin.
Õpetaja: Ja ma panen lihtsalt siia alla praegult niimoodi ajutiselt, et ee, Niimoodi Nagu enamvähem saab. Siis
Õpetaja: saan siin. Ta ootab korra, läheb edasi ja paneb Spinneri ke kinni.
Õpetaja: Aga sellest teisest kohast lõpptulemuses peab jääma Nii nagu meil oli.
Õpetaja: Kui ma panen ju valesti, vaata siis ka. Ju Tuleb Spinner kinni panna. Näed, Spinner tuleb kinni panna. Praegu Ei, Ole kinni,
Õpetaja: et ma pean ta tagasi pärast panema. Aga praegult.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma pean tegema seda.
Õpetaja: Siin ongi natukene keeruline asi. Tegelikult on ikkagi. Aa, no me läheme niikuinii minema, kui kõik on hästi. Nii et on kama selles spinnerist. Selles mõttes Aga et kõik selles mõttes väga korrektselt toimiks,
Õpetaja: siis praegult oleks ikkagi parem, et see Stop Spinner on olemas hoopis eraldi mitte siin selles lõpus, vaid kuidas
Õpetaja: et ta on Nendes blokkides, kus ta peab olema, näiteks siin ja siin.
Õpetaja: Noh, kanda nagu kui tahaks väga korrektselt teha, et ta käitub. Vaata et sa, Manageerid seda Stop Spinnerit iga sõnumi lõpus, Siis ta siis meie. Selle simuleerimise mõttes. Ta nagu toimiks nagu korrektselt, on ju?
Õpetaja: No ma proovin Nüüd väga korra veel. Aa, kuidas Aa, login?
Õpetaja: Neli sekundit oli. Noh, töötab
Õpetaja: Aa, sest et praegult on niimoodi, Vaata, et et seda asja ei jää keegi ootama. Et kui mul siin lõpus, on see Stop Spinner, siis vaata, et see see sõnum saadetakse teele, aga kood jätkub Siin
Õpetaja: kood jätkub siin ja ta paneb Spinneri kinni, et see ei Anna meile korrektset käitumist.
Õpetaja: Pigem on niimoodi.
Õpetaja: No seda asja seda kutsume Pugiks ka. Vaata, et sul ei saa kohe esimese korraga. Nagu päris õiget käitumist, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga kuidas. Ma saaksin nagu vähendada koodi, vaata, et vastab tõele. Vaata, ikkagi Final It saaks kasutada ju, et kui mul on siin see Spinner,
Õpetaja: vaatame, kuidas ta käitub koera. Ma võtan korra selle ära.
Õpetaja: Nii. Ja nüüd hoopis finalis.
Õpetaja: Ja ma võtan. Ma võtan mõlemast ära. Ma Võtan sellest. Ee, ära Sellest võtan ära selle Stopp Spinneri Mõlemast võtan ära,
Õpetaja: et stop. Spinner on ainult hetkel praegult,
Õpetaja: kui kõik väljad on täitmata, aga ma panen ikkagi siia selle Catch I ka mitte Catch I, vaid Finali
Õpetaja: punktiga peab panema selle punkt finali.
Õpetaja: Teen ühe anonüümse käivituse. Mul ei ole finalist. Ei tule mingit vastust
Õpetaja: response Ei, ole? Siin on responsil, on ju
Õpetaja: Ja ütlen, et tegevus, mida käivitada. Ma panen praegu üle mitme koodirea
Õpetaja: ma tegelt ei Pane, ma saan ju meetodid kohe välja kutsuda.
Õpetaja: Ee, this
Õpetaja: stop, spinner. Sest et ma nüüd eeldan, et ta arvestab selle asünkroonsusega. Ta ei Käivita ennem nagu seda final It ennem kui üks nendest on käivitunud.
Õpetaja: Ahah, Noh, see aitaks ka, kui on õige asi välja kutsutud,
Õpetaja: Noh, See on hea, kui on vot Kui oleks Niukene Ee arendus, kus kogu klass arendab, siis vist vigu ei Tuleks,
Õpetaja: Vaatame, kuidas see siis töötab, sest et idee järgi nüüd peaks olema kõik Ja Ja see on ka demo. Ta ei pidanud kahte kohta panema vaid ühte, sest et Ta jooksutab peale
Õpetaja: toimetamist. Den Block is on see? Ma ei tea, kuidas sa. Ma ütlen, et see on hästi, Natukene keeruline on simuleerida nagu seda,
Õpetaja: Sest et ma ei taha seda siia sisse Tegelikult progeda Loading?
Õpetaja: Noh, toob ära, nii et tegelikult ikkagi oli seda vaja,
Õpetaja: Aga oli veel siin ka vaja. Vaata selle Catch bloki sees, aga mitte lõpus.
Õpetaja: Kui paned selle siia alla, lihtsalt sellest Ifelsest välja, siis See käivitub Regardless ja kohe
Õpetaja: Insta. Peaaegu ei näegi. Nagu onju
Õpetaja: nii? Ma arvan, et see koht on, Ma panen selle tagasi ka, on ju.
Õpetaja: Ee. Ja siis mis me teeme, Kuna need stardi start ja stop spinner on niuksed natuke. Universaalses Meetodite mõttes. Ma topiks ta kuskile üldse nagu kuhugi alla. Nagu
Õpetaja: Et niukseid asju, võiksid ju mingid teised asjad ka kasutada, et siis niuksed kommune asjad topitakse alla siin selles Vaates praegult mitte, aga mujal, kus on rohkem sõnumeid ühel lehel. Ja
Õpetaja: kui ta nüüd Spinnerit kasutada, siis ee, nii on,
Õpetaja: ja muidugi peab mõtlema ka seda. Vaata, et praegu ma kasutasin Button Spinnerit, aga. Aga
Õpetaja: kui on nagu mingid tabelid ja asjad laevad, siis seal, on parem Niimoodi, et sa tervet lehte ei näe. Nad on lihtsalt spinner.
Õpetaja: Siis juba spetsiifilisemaks minema, et kui sul mingi Button Spinner, siis sa peaksid panema start Button Spinner
Õpetaja: ja nii edasi. Vaata, on ju, et kui on Niukene üldine spinner, et siis tuleb natukene nagu mõelda, aga ma Ütlengi mõnel lehel nagu see olekski Tegelikult, et. Noh, mul ei ole mõtet näidata mingeid rihve. Nüüd, kui sa tabelit näiteks kõrval pole, vaata, onju? Kõik asjad saab kätte. Vaata siis näitad. On ju
Õpetaja: oma asja, Mäletad? Vaatasime Elronit. Ülemine osa nagu laadis suht kiirelt ee rongi, rongi aegu. Ootasime, onju?
Õpetaja: Võite minna Elronisse ja näha, kuidas see on.
Õpetaja: Aa, teeme siis Comiti ära.
Õpetaja: Tanda Ei, ole meil veel.
Õpetaja: Ee, Teeme siis Teeme Lunch I.
Õpetaja: Saan aru, et ma olen liisiga
Õpetaja: Kaksteist kolmkümmend poole tunni. Kui see
Õpetaja: miiting vä, kas sa tahaks, Me teeksime Lunch I Natuke hiljem? Siis kuidagi sobib praegu, et
Õpetaja: mängib välja. Okei, teeme niimoodi. Aga teeme siis kohe. Tõmbame joone alla. Ee, ja. Ja okei, kas on. Okei, me siis alustame. Sinu juhul kui vaata. Jah, ee, kaksteist. Viiskümmend vä. Ei,
Õpetaja: no kell ongi Peaaegu Juba Teeme siis täistunnil lihtsalt Sobib viiskümmend. Min sa pausi
Õpetaja: Aga proovime siis täistunnile olla. Tagasi. Kes, ee, kes saavad.